how does someone really know they're a
writer maybe they just like the idea
of being a writer the identity of it no
it's a good question
as always um i found
with actors as well people who i've come
in contact with
that some people like to play the role
and others like to actually do the work
and so there's a uh you can see because
when it starts getting difficult
those who want to play the role go um
this is hard and then
it becomes like well do you really want
to do this and you know writers
i always say writers write you know
there's writers are a special breed
you know what i mean um i know if it's
hard to explain
but you're the one up at two o'clock in
the morning with
passion and you can't to use a double
negative not right
you know it's it's something that you
that's in your blood it's in your dna
to be a creative person like that so
those people you know i said i used to
work in a restaurant as a waiter and
there were some
people who wanted to be actors and
writers as well no i'm working on the
thing and they never finish something
that's also another indication where you
can't see it through
where this person who writes yeah it's
it's
there's a lot of fear involved because
it may be crap you know you may not
you may not be at a level where you want
to be but you have to get through that
to get to the other side to master
anything
um martial arts whatever it is that
you're studying
so a lot of the people wanted to be
actors
you know liked the you know i'm brooding
yeah but
you know i'm an actor you know wearing
the leather jacket and you said well
you're going on auditions
well no are you taking classes well no
you know i have a good look
okay that'll get only so far you know
what i mean so i think um
you can some people may try try writing
like say oh i think i'd like to write a
screenplay which is fantastic
it might not be the um
you know maybe novel writing is better
suited or maybe both of them are not you
know it takes a big commitment so
i think you find your way but for me
since i was 11 i knew that this was kind
of my calling
you know making movies and things when
we were we were shooting films
short movies at 11 years old i i knew
you know because i nothing would would
stray me from that
so um yeah i think it's uh
i think you either find out that it's
not what you really are passionate about
or you early on you know it's your
passion
and nothing's going to stop you from it
so i think that's what
what designates you know a writer for
the long haul
and the test of when things are
uncomfortable and
looks like it's not going to happen yeah
i always say failure is
um is a test to see how badly you want
it
you know and and this life of a writer
is filled with rejection
failure and criticism and it's not going
to go away even when you start working
in fact the stakes i think are even
higher because then there's
money involved and contracts and
pressure like
i have to work under a deadline
and that was the first thing that was
difficult for me when i started working
professionally
is that you're supposed to be creative
under a deadline and how can you do that
and some when you're working on your
specs
it's open-ended right you well i won't
work today or i'll go to the beach
and when it becomes your job it's the
job with any responsibility like a job
has to do you clock in and you know your
clock in time might be
you know three in the afternoon as long
as you get those pages done
you know at a certain time so
how did you learn to write screenplays
i don't know if i still know but you
know how did i learn how to write
screenplays um
well early on as a kid
when i was making films with my friend
we just
we wrote by on pen and paper
and just made a couple of notes and
really didn't know what we were kind of
doing but we knew we had to have
something on paper
and i'm not sure if we actually read a
screenplay per se or not because a lot
of times
scripts in that those days were hard to
find you know you couldn't just say oh
i'm going to look up on the internet
blah blah you know unless you were
working in the business
you're not going to find a screenplay
unless you have someone in the business
so
we started with pen and paper and then
eventually realized you know moving into
high school let's say
because i was when we were 11 years old
and in middle school realized that we
had to have some sort of
you can't just shoot the movie make it
up as you go and so we started
writing screenplays and um after we
sort of veered off on our separate paths
my friend making his own you know we had
our own
camps of actors and you know a stable of
people
i remember in high school actually
physically writing
typing you know my script it was like 60
pages
now it was a short but it wasn't a
feature either so it was kind of this
weird nebulous
place but it was you know exterior blah
blah
and um of course then before college
is when the real studying began you know
with
books and then learning how to like
write a conventional screenplay as you
would as you would
think um but yeah basically it was
it was winging it at the beginning and
then moving into sort of like well i
should probably study
you know if i'm going to want to work
someday and then college was definitely
you know film school was definitely the
study of
the screenplay were there any books you
picked up before you entered the first
semester
yeah sid field's book which is a famous
one
i have an autographed copy oh nice um
and
of course joseph campbell and
um there was i don't remember the other
ones but the ones that you would think
and then it was just getting on to to
writing you know
and also seeing screenplays and in
classes we would be given scripts as
well there was more access to that
and our teachers were always industry
professionals
so that helped as well for them to sort
of you know train us and keep us in the
in the uh you know guide us along into
the way of
this is how scripts written at least you
know
in hollywood per se would you as a class
go through it like
you know there'd be 50 copies passed out
and then you'd read it
like how did yeah there was one class
that we each got a copy of
the script and it would movie that i
think was um
going to be made and the teacher was
going to make the film
so we got to see how a movie was broken
down
and it's you know what i mean so we
could see that from a writer's
perspective like oh
it has to be broken into days and you
know
it's not filmed in order and all these
things that you know sometimes writers
who are just starting out don't think
about you know that a movie has to be
broken down
into how many days you can't have too
many scenes for a particular budget
because how many scenes are you gonna
shoot per day
you know these type of things so um it
was a great study in
the ask the actual um you know being a
savvy production
writer which i think is important as
well
and did they ever make the movie that
teacher oh geez i don't remember oh okay
maybe maybe not i'm not sure i wonder if
you got to see that no i didn't no
it was probably proposed and maybe
probably couldn't get the financing you
know
so yeah would the students give feedback
would they become their own sort of like
note givers or was it simply just to
read along
yeah i know i don't think he was
interested in in feedback
sounds like a writer okay yeah writer
producer director
yeah i don't think he was like i don't
you're supposed to listen to me not the
other way around
i wasn't sure if that was how yeah the
class was yeah well other classes that
we
wrote screenplays in our own you know
we'd get feedback
on our own scripts you know from from
our
our collective class which was small
luckily i think one class
we had eight people so it wasn't like
you know like a film studies class we
have 300 people
so and then you know we'd each give
notes and the teacher would give notes
and you know at the end of the
semester we have a finished script so
that's really in
in film school when i started to you
know
write feature-length screenplays per se
how long did it take you to write where
you felt you were writing at a
professional level
hmm probably five
feature-length screenplays because it
was my fifth spec that actually
um was optioned and sold
so i'm like well i must be doing
something right
sure but it took about in the ones
before were kind of
bumbling and there was you know it
wasn't obviously quite up to par
to compete those those are the ones that
we see you have to get out of your
system
you know the first two or three and a
lot of many times um
writers write their first script and
they're like where's my agent you know
this is
their first script of their first draft
you know and say this is
brilliant and you're like well the first
of anything is not going to be
unless you're a genius which you very
well may be but
most the time there's so many things
that so many moving parts
you know that it's hard even at best to
get it like wow this is
you know 100 there so
that takes time and so about the fifth
one
um you know it was about okay i think
i've got this
under control you know and then you know
and then
from that also that was a learning
experience to work with producers
because it's one thing to write your
script it's another to
now it's real you know where you don't
live in your bubble and you're like
everything's exactly the way i want
and you're like well now it's being
taken away from me
and i have to compromise and make
changes and there's budgets and all
sorts of things you know and you stick
to
you stick to the creative aspects of it
because you wrote it but
you have to realize that filmmaking is a
collaborative
you know art form and there's other
people involved starts with the script
but a script is just a script you know
it's words on paper it has to be brought
elevated to actors and someone to
direct it and you know so i think it was
the fifth
my fifth back and so not just the fact
that
you were being hired to do something but
was it also
the ease or the the comfort in your own
skin of like
okay i'm working with other people and
they may not like this and i'm going to
get feedback
and i'm going to be okay with that or
what was there like something that also
shifted
not just the fact that you got these
jobs which is huge but i mean did you
also feel like
oh yeah okay yeah this is i'm doing this
yeah but even now
to a certain extent you know there's
still that um
with an artist i don't think it ever
goes away especially writers where you
know this voice is going oh my gosh this
is the one that
they find out you're a fraud you
actually were able to fool them
you know 16 times and now is the one
where they catch you
you know um but it's a constant learning
experience and i always say i get
butterflies before every job because
i respect it such and i don't take it
for granted
like oh this will be a walk in the park
or i know how to do this
i do but every time out is different
every script's different every
producer's different so it's not going
to be the same as last time so you can't
say well this last one
and some are easy and some are just the
worst thing ever
you know i mean i'm not saying the worst
thing ever but some are very difficult
and you just wonder like wow how is it
this one is so much
so much more difficult than the last
that was a breeze and you don't know
i mean it's just a weird combination of
of elements you know and it's so uh
but it's better yes absolutely after i'm
working on my 40th screenplay so i you
know
but i still like i say bow down to the
craft been and respect it because i
learned something every time that i
didn't know before then i should be open
to that i think writers should be
should we never you get to a plateau and
you're like i know everything
you know a master martial artist is is
not only living it but also
continuing to learn you know so it's
like that kind of
i keep using martial arts because i'm
studying right now a little bit
yeah so it's it's helpful in the in the
writing aspect
philosophy of almost the same thing
because you know
the first moves are like that's not it
you have to do this
now the pressure has to be on that foot
you keep but if you just
keep at it you know and be open to
learning
you know and with martial arts would you
say it's
50 physical 50 mental
i think well i i'm not
deep into it i've been you know i've
been interested for many years but
a lot of it is mental and the
physicality is you can be a small person
and still ward off an attack because of
what you know you know what i mean it's
it's using force against
it's using you know against your own you
know what i mean it's like
you don't have to be hercules in person
to defend yourself
but it's not about defense you know i'm
just saying but writing
it's it's a discipline
and i think it should be followed as
such and
it's a lifelong learning process so
um like i say even after so many scripts
some are terrible some are the best i've
ever written and i
i keep striving to have the next one be
better than the last one
and there are a lot of factors when it
ends up when you actually have a movie
that's filmed
it's out of your control you you write
the script but you're not there
directing it you're not there producing
it there's a lot of
there's a lot of choices that can fall
short from what your vision of it
becomes so at that point you have to
step back and just go
well on to the next one you know and it
doesn't mean you don't care
but you can't care so much that every
time you're just destroyed
you know and and that's why i say about
detachment is so important over the long
haul
because it doesn't mean you don't care
and believe me still i'm making changes
now in a script and i'm just like
you know i care but i have to get this
thing
through the conveyor belt you know into
the into production so um
you know it's a lot less stressful for
you over the long haul
to care but just sort of be
don't hang on too tightly you know
um so that's just my personal experience
do you think going back to the analogy
of
martial arts that writing is
similar 50 i wouldn't want to say
physical
but the act of writing and and you know
and then the other
50 is like this mental thing of showing
up
every day not putting it off not going
to the beach
and not letting the little voice say
this is horrible i'm not going to finish
this
and and yeah yes and a lot of it is feel
too
you know writing is not just um
mechanical
there's a there's feel like you're like
you're sculpting i think like with
clay you know you're writing a scene but
your your
technique is through you know a laptop
or whatever you write on
and it's coming out here onto the page
and so
with that it's a combination of all
things mental physical
but also um one you know it's it's
amazing because once when you feel
and you get a move right and you don't
have to think about it
it's like you know and you but how would
this person ever study for so many years
and do all these different things
because it just same way of
screenwriting how could you study and
know all these different things because
you just keep doing it again
and again and again you know and that's
back to your earlier comment about who's
a writer and who's not
if you're a writer you're right you
don't talk about it
you know hemingway had a quote about
that writers don't talk about their
stuff they're too busy
working and what i mean about that is
like oh i'm
you know doing my pages and this and
that which is fine but
you better be doing the pages you're
talking about you know what i mean
otherwise it's just
you're doing more talking about your
work than actually doing the work
and it's always about the work so we can
talk about our work but
if there is no work that's real and i'm
not saying you have to sell something
either you know writers who write you
you're absolutely a writer
you know but if you if you find that
it's not for you
that's okay too because i see people
come up against that wall all the time
and they're fighting desperately it's
like you let go it's okay to let go if
it's not right for you
why do you want to try to force it you
know i mean because it's a long
it's up and down journey to be a writer
you know
so it's you that's why i would say you
have to really love it more than
anything else
because it's going to be it's going to
break your heart
and it's going to be the the best thing
you've ever
experienced in your life at the same
time what makes the first draft of a
screenplay crucial to a writer's success
hmm i'm glad you asked
[Laughter]
because there's a lot of theories going
around that the first draft can be crap
you know and it has to be and i don't
believe that it has to be crap
absolutely not and
ernest lehman who the great six-time
nominated academy award six-time
nominated screenwriter
who did west side story north by
northwest
sweet smell of success he said
the first draft is dangerously important
because it's difficult now this next
part is
paraphrasing to totally change something
into another direction
once you you've had it down and it is
difficult it's like building a house
and then having the walls don't quite
have the right structure and the windows
so you know you have to go back in and
now you're dismantling things to try to
rewrite it
and everybody has their own way of
working which is fantastic whatever's
best for you
but i always think why would you waste
the time
that it takes to write a first draft and
know that it's not going to be good
and know that 60 70 percent of it is
going to be thrown out or rearranged or
maybe not even used
to get a kernel of of something that can
be used
and i always say by the way when you
start working
which is the intent i suppose of
screenwriters is to work
meaning they're being hired to write
scripts that you know going
produced into movies is that you can't
turn in
a crappy first draft you'll be fired
so on assignment jobs
my first draft has to be really pretty
good to work with it can't be like well
that was a nice pass you know now we're
behind in development you know sort of
and so you want i've trained myself over
the years to really and had to
have the first draft to be really solid
because the outline was really solid
and that's another discussion about
outlines
and also people well i just wing it i
you know i sit down i write a script and
then you get lost in page 40 and you
can't really see the rest
of where you're going you know and so it
becomes a muddled mess and it's like
what you know
and i know it sounds that it's like some
kind of formula like well just do this
this and this
but sort of when you start writing
professionally there are steps
that's how you're paid too it's steps so
we turn in the first draft and then
we have notes and then we execute the
second
and we move on and on so um
yes the first draft i believe is really
important you know and it doesn't have
to be perfect
there shouldn't be any pressure like i
can't write it because i know it's bad
but
if you're if you've already done like
really the heavy lifting in the outline
then the first draft should kind of kind
of be a breeze
because you've already kind of in a way
seen the film
worked it out before you've ever gone to
pages
you know pages of the actual screenplay
and
i have found that every time because the
more time you work on the outline
the more details and and again now
people are going to say
it stifles my creativity there's no room
there's complete room for freedom and
creativity
but you have a safety net you're not
falling off that high wire
and dropping down the canyon into the
river below
you're the boom you know you've got the
net that that captures you
and so many things come out while i'm
writing the script
that i never thought of in the outline
because i'm in that world
and i have that that room to play and go
this way but i know what's coming next
because i've already thought of it you
know kind of thing so
the first draft i think is really
important just to play devil's advocate
what if
i say well i'm already hesitant as a
writer i already don't believe in my
ability so if i do a quote vomit draft
that helps me sit down and and
and realize okay wait maybe this isn't
that bad
and if i couldn't do that vomit draft
then i
wouldn't write okay it's to me it's kind
of like rolling the dice i suppose i
don't know
okay all right i like vomiting i don't
like vomiting i don't know
um okay uh i get it i understand
uh but my point again a hammer back
there's no vomit draft when you start
working
i haven't experienced it maybe some
people have they'll get pages
i'll see in a month you know do whatever
you want to do the investors don't care
the network has no idea what you're
doing because
it's just you know so as i say writing
specs i believe is a training ground
right because that's how you learn to
write bad spec after bad specting
becomes a good spec and next time you
learn from this bob out in the notes and
how to execute notes
that's how you start learning how to
write screenplays because
you write bad spec you learn from your
mistakes you get notes
you take you know the blows and you come
back stronger next time what not to do
and you become a more efficient
screenwriter
rather than wasting time you're not
going to be able to waste time when
you're working professionally
you're going to be under a contract and
i know i'm coming from that angle but
it's the only angle i can come from
because
that's my experience as of the last 20
years so i do remember when i was
writing the specs in college and
you know i still write specs but it's
different because they're on my own time
you know and there's no pressure there
but if you've never sold anything
you know you again i i suppose
i guess we could have the argument with
you know but i'm just saying
i think it's great to train yourself now
to sort of be more structured
if you're a writer who wants to work in
the hollywood system
hollywood system meaning a producer
hires you
to write a screenplay or they hire you
there to buy your screenplay you're
gonna have to do rewrites on it and
things like that
so if you hired an architect and they
give you this vomit draft of the
blueprints
it probably is not going to fly probably
and the architect might go hey look at
my other homes you know and
that's not the way i work man you know i
like to just wing it you're like
why is the window facing up i don't
underst you know what are we looking at
so
um i think it's yeah i think um
and i know people just have to i wish i
could just
vomit a script out you know where it's
like soup to nuts it's it's all done
it's perfect but that vomiting can be
done in the outline
where you're like wow making those
mistakes there before you ever
go to the screenplay and then like i
said
the screenplay should be a pleasurable
experience it should be like
huh and today i did five more pages you
know what because i know what i'm doing
i've lived with the characters
i'm not first seeing them on this blank
page of the screenplay
i've i've lived with them in the outline
i
i know what's going to happen i know the
intent of the scene and stuff
again always comes out brilliant stuff
that you go that would be great
because you're living in that world
you're not suddenly trying to make it up
as you go
you can do that in the outline nobody's
going to see the outline i mean
eventually
they will see it but what i'm saying is
um
that's like the pre-blueprint you know
the pre the pre-screenplay is the
outline
and the more time you spend on that
story the easier the script is going to
be to write and
and and you're going to know more about
it you're going to see the story in your
head
and to continue that
not every every time that the outline's
accepted
and you go to script let's say are they
going to like the script either and that
happens too all the time
happens recently where it's like yeah
but you agreed to didn't we agree to the
outline
but when they see the finished product
this part doesn't work they thought it
did
and so um you know it's like if the
house was built and you go well in the
blueprints i kind of
liked that but now i don't so that
happens too you have to be prepared for
that
and other times there's hardly i've done
a script where
they're like we hardly have any notes
you're like oh my gosh that's never
happened
i think because of the solid outline
what makes a great story i think what
makes a great story is something that
someone can watch and have an emotional
response to
and and perhaps learn something from or
be uplifted by and you can
really see that the the person creating
the film or whatever is really
passionate about their
their point of view or their voice and
also something that you personally if
you're going to write that story
are passionate about as well you know
great stories as you can see with films
stand the test of time so there's a
reason why we go back and we keep seeing
these movies over and over again
that that you know in the pantheon of
cinema that
why do they touch us and you know from
people around the world
because it's like a universal theme you
know
good versus evil it's a basic one you
know but it's something
that transcends um uh
countries it just it finds the essence
of
the human condition so and that's
uh honestly hard to find but you people
you find it you try to stick that
interject you know into
what stories you you want to tell as a
writer or filmmaker
i mean i know you have your outline but
at what point are you really honing in
on that dialogue
um i you know when i'm doing the outline
i'm not
if i have a line that comes up you know
i'll throw it in just for my own
sake so i remember it but i'm i'm
running those scenes in my head
you know about what what people are
going to say and you know
the characters and when you know this is
the first time you're going to sit down
and
craft the scene so you two have never
been together
and i have to write it and if i if i
stand that character's voice in my head
for the most part it'll continue through
but then you do another pass and
redefine and say man they really
wouldn't say that and
and this and that so um you know first
draft is good for that is to be
with your characters and sort of sussing
out
the first time and it may not be perfect
it won't be
about their voice because you got to
find it you got to get a handle on that
for the different characters um so
uh it helps you know like when you do
your character profiles
if you decide to sit down like an actor
would and really suss it out
to think of how this character speaks
what their point of view is you know
things like that because many times i do
read scripts and
you could take the names off from
characters and they kind of sound
like the same person and that's
something you don't want
it should be like you take the names off
and i go ah i knew who that is
oh i know what this is you know it has
to be that distinct because otherwise it
just all blends into
people just saying things and they
people don't speak the same way
you know and at what point do you thin
out the dialogue or
maybe you don't need to in that you
start to read it and go you know
this just sounds too like people
wouldn't really say this let me thin
this out
have it be more modest second draft okay
yeah or usually gets the the notes about
cut this speech or
you know cut the first line out you're
saying the same thing and
and that's you know it's second draft
should be more
you know redefining not like throw that
out
let's you know and i've worked on
scripts like that you know as a script
doctor
where it's like this is complete you see
everything that you're reading here yeah
you can't use it oh it gives you the
title the character names
everything's got to be recalibrated
rewritten
um so second draft is great for going
through that and polishing up and
then you know you put it away for a week
and you come back to it
and it really is glaring like did i
write that you know
um this does it bumps for me this
character doesn't sound like
and and many times uh people find it's
good to speak the dialogue
aloud you know or have table reads
where they can hear it uh
you know like like they do with plays
you know it's like that doesn't quite
sound like that character
and then an actor is a good is a good
person for that to really you know read
it and go
this kind of doesn't you know what i
mean like in a reading an actor would
take the character in and
and go it's done right sound right you
know okay you know if you're
workshopping that type of thing
if if someone can't get a bunch of
actors together for whatever reason
would it be helpful maybe to speak into
a tape recorder their idea oh sure
and the software is the software has um
you know you can put it it really read
the script for you you can listen
so but the voice is is okay you know
but yeah it'd be good i speak
you know the dialogue people probably
what's the guy talking to himself you
know
[Laughter]
like oh i'm crazy i decided to be a
writer you know
these people leave you alone on the
street yeah exactly yeah
i'm writing i'm writing constantly in my
head you know
how do you know you're getting the
dialogue right again
i i feel you know i mean personally for
me it's a feel and a feeling
and sound you know and and vision
about the you have to really know your
characters to write each one
individually and what they would say
and more importantly what they would not
you know a lot of time dialogue is
written and
i see a scene and i'm like you know
this character doesn't have to say that
line let them
emote you know with you know 60 feet on
the screen with a look
rather than you know you want to err on
action
first and dialogue second you know so um
dialogue is extremely important but
that shouldn't drive your you know it
shouldn't drive
the narrative by people speaking because
most time people don't say what they
mean
you know so a lot of times it's going to
be like the subtext below that about
what they
really mean you know dialogues
it's hard to do well you know you read
things and like i said you've got
characters that
all sound the same and it's just sort of
like it sits there on the page and it's
not
you know i could strip the name off and
i would go i they both sound like the
same person
you know so it it takes time
and and like we discussed earlier about
maybe
you know tape it you know with your
phone or something to listen back and if
it doesn't say you know there's a thing
about sound
the way people talk their diction what
they would
what they would say what they wouldn't
say what they would reveal and not you
know
the tone the tone sure exactly because
you could say one thing it would sound
completely friendly and kind of another
and it's just a matter of tone
and then when you start working with
actors that's like the workshop level
because
they'll take your piece and go okay and
then internalize it and then go
this doesn't because i've seen it on
sets where the actors like
i don't this doesn't work for me
you know i need to change this and it's
like okay songs are not
too changed because you know you take
that line out earlier
you know we're not talking about a big
rewrite but you know i mean
internalizing it and saying
because now i know my my character
wouldn't really say that
and you go okay that's fair you know in
writing it i thought it would and now on
the set it doesn't work
you know so there's there's that thing
so it's constant
evolving uh you know entity is
the screenplay you know because you're
you're shooting it for the first time
and
you know it's create creative process
things there's choices made on the set
all the time
in what ways does a screenwriter
disrespect format
by not learning format pretty much
um i know many people say format who
cares
and there are there's no rule book
there's there's a accepted way that
scripts are written of course
and so people who read scripts a lot are
going to expect a script to be
written that way exterior you know with
slug with the
location header followed by description
followed by
dialogue and there are particular
ways of doing that but it's not
writing the script in crayon you know i
mean it's
and importantly enough what i always see
is
is if something's not clear and so when
you read a script
and the style isn't clear or i'm like
was that character in the
car you know i don't it's confusing
that's going to kill you because a
reader is going to get your script and
they're going to scan it they're going
to you know
they're not going to read word for word
you know they scan the script they have
a lot of scripts to read readers
and if it keeps bumping that way
and it gets confusing you have to go
back and turn the page back and say i
didn't quite oh it's you know
it's not going to reflect well upon you
as a writer or the project
and sometimes people say well you know
they'll they'll see through
you know all that stuff to my genius of
how the idea is
there's a lot of great screenplays out
there so there's no need to weed through
you know a bunch of mess to try to find
the genius idea in there you know it's
all about the execution
of that idea so format is extremely
important because also
it shows if i'm the script that i'm
reading
i could look at the title page and then
i flip to page one just one page and i
can see
you know okay maybe this person is a
professional writer or maybe they're not
but format will give you away every time
because of what you don't know
and so if it doesn't look like a script
you know
it's going to be hard to get through it
and understand the nature of how a
script is written
to read it and that's the thing i want
to read the script and be able to see it
and understand and format
is what does that so people maybe
mistake
novel writing the same format with with
yeah there's also two camps about that
where you know
it doesn't matter i want to write what's
in the character's head you know and the
other camp is
you can only write what you can see or
hear on the screen
period and you can deviate but when you
start to read scripts that read like a
novel
you know he walked to the window and
stared out thinking about his girlfriend
back when he was 12
how do you show that you're telling me
that if you show that where he picks up
a picture and he sees his girlfriend at
12 or i say it in dialogue
those are two ways to do it
cinematically but the other way is just
telling us you know and for a director
to read that an actor might go okay
that's all think about but how am i
gonna show that
so that you know there's two camps
vying for that and i tend to err on
uh you can only write where you can show
so how do you keep the audience engaged
in the script you keep them engaged by
making them work you know they they're
they're a
an observer of the movie and you're
leading him along the path but like
billy wilder said you give an audience
you you allow an audience to add up two
plus two equals four they're going to
love you forever
right so we want to watch a movie but we
also want to
oh you know yeah that you know setups
payoffs
i had this discussion recently with
another writer goes well i don't
write a lot of those you know setups and
stuff like the commercial movies you
write i was like
okay um but setups
we love that you know because in act one
when we set up this thing
it saves in act two and we go that's the
i wondered why they showed the
the keys in the thing right everything's
for a reason
nothing in there is is left to chance
you know what i mean
um so you keep an audience engaged by
interesting characters too
you know so a setup is a little clue
yeah setups and then sometimes the setup
is not paid off you know there's there's
films
many times maybe like in a noir or
something you go you thought was gonna
and it doesn't you're like that's okay
but
when you when you have little setups
that that later on
you know oh my gosh um that's why he
left the knife in the thing because he
thought
you know and so when you get that you're
now being you're active
in your mind not just passive watching a
movie go by
you know it becomes more interesting you
know
um i don't know just
so clues but some of them can be false
sure
to keep them and feel on their toes and
um
twists and turns are extremely important
we don't want to just go ah
you know the minute that you you bring
us along and think we're going one way
we sag on another
you know that that's going to keep my
interest you know well yeah
where it's not just i've seen this
before you know what's going to happen
the killer's going to be behind the door
with the thing and then when that
doesn't happen you're like oh
you know it didn't wow it's different
it's refreshing you know
rather than like a formulaic cookie
cutter i've seen this a million times
before
which happens you know or also the
the benevolent nature of the character
like
you think somebody is right in their
camp sure
yeah characters as well uh changing
sides and allegiance
and you know all that stuff is that's
why um
you have to have it all throughout to
make it interesting to make us
want to or in a screenplay want to turn
that page
for like uh you know i want to have a
page turner
just like that's the way the movie's
going to be hopefully a page turner you
know
i can't wait to the next scene you know
um cliffhangers
you know it's a tv show cliffhanger we
end up this episode they come at the end
of the cliff
you know they're going to go in the next
oh you caught my
no they got saved you know
or especially like in films where
everybody seems dark
in terms of their motives but actually
you find out like i'm thinking of margin
call
was great great did you watch martial no
oh you didn't see that okay
yeah it was about um well we'll skip it
it's good but everybody seems
except for stanley tucci's character but
most people there you're like
all of the characters their motives seem
you know this is during the recession
and you're not sure who's going to lose
their job right right
who's kind of quote selling out and uh
yeah just it keeps you on your toes
because you're not sure
yeah that that definitely keep an
audience watching you know
look at some of the like i say some of
the best films um
and and look at those and say how did
that work you know
um and again characters too we want to
go on the ride
where we like these characters that's
another thing too when i read the script
i'm like we want to care about them
it's another thing when i read a script
i'm like i don't really care about
just because they're here on the page
right yeah you know i want to i want to
root for them
you know or or be surprised or you know
something some kind of emotional
response
let's say glenn gary glenn ross yeah so
not all of the characters in fact many
of them were not likable
sure but there was something in them
like to say jack lemmon's character yeah
you cared about him right you saw the
desperation and you wanted
you were you know there would be
they weren't maybe necessarily people
you'd want to work with yeah there was
something in them that you cared for
yeah that's hard to craft i mean
absolutely
what do new screen writers need to know
about story structure
what would you teach them a story
structure that you have to have an idea
that
that can can fill
let's say a screenplay many times
someone sits down to write they say i
have an idea for script and
it really quite isn't a fully fleshed
out story with a beginning
a middle and an end and so
i would say before you sit down you can
have a kernel of an idea which
blossoms into something bigger but try
to work on it where
you can step back away and get is this a
movie
as we know movies you know is it going
to be big enough
um and there are small stories i'm not
saying that small stories aren't movies
but
if you're going to write a feature film
for
you know big hollywood for you know 4
000 screens
it may not be this little idea
you know and sometimes even when i see
an outline there's not enough
story there to facilitate 100 pages
you know you think it is and you're like
well you kind of skipped over most of
the second act here
you didn't quite think through all that
and structure is extremely important so
screenplays are built on
you know telling the story um so
your story was originally i mean your
your question about
structure do you think then a lot of
people
just have a great beginning and then a a
a
finishing and then in the middle is very
muddy yes
it's always muddy in the middle and the
first act is the easiest
setup because it's all set up right
we're all setting up the you know the
thing
and then you have to go on the journey
in act two and that's where it starts to
get
more difficult because like i say if
you're just
winging a script it's always those big
barren wasteland in the middle that's
really
you know you could know the ending
hopefully it'll get you there
i know the ending scene fantastic you
know where you have to get but all that
stuff in between
you know that that always seems to be
the issue
is the is the big let's say it's act two
the middle
the middle part which is pretty much the
meat and potatoes of
you know the movie
what has helped you get to a better
second act
well knowing the ending for sure but
also um
really getting to the essence of what
what am i trying to do with this story
you know what i mean what's um what's my
theme
what is my what's this about what's
you know is it just well two people on a
car ride and they drive across the
country
great that could be an amazing story but
what happens what is it about you know
what's the what's the problem
what what do they have to face what to
get to
that ending part and
working on an outline i hate to refer
back to that is working on the story
so you just and sometimes
story you think it's something's there
and it doesn't work
you know and other times i i've done
many drafts of an outline where i
couldn't find the story and i kept
trying to fight it and then i realized
that it had to do
with characters and so the story was
there the a b
c and d of it but it still wasn't
working
so a lot of times you can have an idea
which you have to work at the i
you have to work it into its you know
it's full essence of what it can be and
sometimes
it you may want to just leave it alone
and say you know what i don't think
that's
i don't think that's a story that i can
manage together and i'm going to move on
to something else that's okay too
do you think a lot of people have
trouble letting go of their stories like
what if it's a very personal story
well yeah well if it's a personal story
um
it would be hard to let go trying to
force it but then
i might say maybe it's not meant to be a
screenplay maybe it's meant to be
something else maybe a book
you know or i don't know what what
uh it could be but and that's for the
writer to decide if it really is not
it's not working and it's okay to move
on to something else
there's no no harm no foul you know have
you done that where you're like you know
what i i love these characters but for
some reason
this isn't going i mean for things that
you've written on your own yes and paid
to write
uh i i have a hard time
i'm so strict about it has to be like
like a really good idea of my own that
it sort of i have this inner filter that
it limits that unfortunately so
um yeah many times i've said this one
just is not
it's not working and other ones you
other ones you see right away because
the characters are so vibrant and alive
and you're like yeah i can
i can see this you know this is what
what it works and
like i said there's no there's no harm
in maybe putting it aside too
maybe another time as you can become a
more experienced writer that you can go
back to it
and work on it so nothing's ever dead
you know you don't have to
discard it completely um nor do i think
you should but
to move on is okay as well you put it in
you know in the
in the notebook and say oh you know and
that's how you build ideas that's how
you build an arsenal of stuff that you
can go back and work on and keep your
well and your creative well
full you know
you've also talked about just living
life as well to
how do you know when aside from not
being on an assignment
that it's time to go and and fill the
well because
i know that the life behind the computer
can get very wonderful
yes i hate uh sitting at the keyboard
it means it's a necessity but um
you also have to live your life and like
we were talking about
that you know an authentic life outside
your comfort zone
is a good thing you know do things that
you're afraid of i don't mean jump off a
cliff but
um i was skydiving once you know and
that was
uh one time only
[Laughter]
but it wasn't just to go oh i mean some
people were going and and
they said hey you want to come and i'm
like yeah i do and it's not something i
would ever do again and i'm not a
daredevil
type person but it was amazing
experience
and those kind of experiences you know
you can write into your projects where
it's not just you're living in a little
protected bubble where you're writing
stuff that you've seen on television or
movies where you're just regurgitating
which could be cliches to begin with
which probably are
you know that that's where your own
personal experience comes into
characters and
and your unique voice and things because
i've lived it i went to
blah blah i've been you know i've been
there
you know type of thing so yeah writers
should have interesting lives
if possible yeah because i was watching
a master class with david sedaris
oh yes it's hilarious and he picks up
garbage i guess
around the little town that he lives in
wow and he says
that you know he wears his vest and he
does it and people don't realize
a lot of times that he's this writer
this author sure
so sometimes they'll be like oh sir you
actually missed a piece over here
and he goes with it yeah and he says i
would have this is this gets me out
this is where i'm able to see people
in ways that i wouldn't see them when
i'm speaking in front they're not going
to talk to me like that you know and he
goes with it any any
oh yeah sure sorry about that and so
that's part of his way he's doing a good
thing
and he also gets out and interacts with
people and he's he's observing life too
you know as a
actor or writer it's good to observe the
world around you get off the phone you
know
and actually go oh my gosh that's
interest this is real life out here you
know this interesting character or
oh i heard that little at the coffee
shop this person said that thing
you know write it down in your notebook
these are these are cool little things
you can start building upon
as being it's part of your job to be an
observer
as well as an adventurer you know i
think so i mean i don't mean
you know take off quit your job and you
know
sail across the world if that's your
thing but you can do it like you say
um with small things that just are kind
of different like
we normally wouldn't do that and don't
be afraid to try that
because it all will it all will filter
back
hopefully into your work you know it's
your writing so when someone reads
something it won't be
i saw this scene in last week on
television you know or
you know what i mean it's sort of like
different fresh unique
because it's it's personal it's it's a
personal experience you know
it feels like in some ways there's less
places to go these days you know a lot
of bookstores aren't around anymore yes
i know
and that used to be one place where you
could just get out you know yes
and yeah you can go to a coffee shop and
there's some great ones but people are
also busy with headphones
um they're all um doing their own thing
you know not sort of like i'm in my own
little world you're in your
right world yeah yeah but it is helpful
because you just don't know
i mean aside from from maybe vacations
or something what are some other things
you do to
get yourself out of that well just try
to get out in the world you know try to
you know i tend to be an introvert
sometimes when i'm working so then you
got to be like
get out of there you know go go uh
it's not like it hasn't been done in the
past obviously but you have to
you have to keep yourself in check that
you don't it doesn't become like you
know 80 20
of 80 introvert 20 you know when it was
more before
because it can slip very easily that way
where you're like uh
i don't want to go out i want to do this
thing um
just being around people too good bad
and different whatever
sure you know sure yeah i see all sorts
of stuff out there yeah
yeah was it jackie gleason who said his
advice for like people then the industry
was get out
like don't be a shut-in and also i think
get out of
the the business you know because
hollywood is like this weird little
place
where everybody around is talking about
the business you know and you're like
is there anybody saving lives here at
this party do we have a doctor or
something you know i mean
let me know at times it really is like
you know
and we all want to congregate together
because everybody's bibbidi-bobbidi
network
but many times it's really great you
know some big actor i remember his his
best friends are not
even in the business they're just you
know
people not in the film business and
you're like yeah that's refreshing you
know
i have both both you know in and out
you know so um it's good to have a nice
mix
but if you're just around that only it's
sort of like this fake world you know
kind of thing so
what structure have you used the most
often the pseudo 3 act
but you know for tv movies it's
nine eight acts and a quota at the end
so
it's um you know it's about
nine to 11 pages per act but the first
one's the longest
which i like uh breaking it up that way
because it seems
a lot less you know this big middle act
you know let's say
i'm just paraphrasing you know let's say
act two starts on page 20
you know goes to 80. you know it's 60
pages you know but if you but if it's
you're like oh i'm not even through act
2 but
if you're sort of like well i've done 11
pages i'm now into act
3. you know it's sort of
structured in that way but um
[Music]
you know specs are the basic around act
three kind of structure type thing
you know so forgive me with tv
because sitcoms aren't aren't maybe what
they used to be
and you're you're watching more
serialized content yes without breaks
yeah
so it's it's changed then so the sitcom
structure was one thing
yeah i'm talking about i mean um like
network television
which you still have commercials but
yeah streaming there's no
you can it would be the same as a movie
almost
yeah okay i would think yeah i mean this
the scripts i've read
you know streaming they they have the
ability just to have
you know i mean 35 minutes is you know
kind of thing i mean the game of thrones
were
over an hour some of them were like hour
five maybe
you know which you'd never find on
network tv it'd be like
the 60 minutes or on to the next thing
right right but then there's a
continuation so
yeah there's more there's more um
[Music]
i think it's great there's more room to
to play with that
you know on streaming platforms and
things
you know it didn't have to be adhere to
this exact like it's got to be you know
like the old
it was um half hours 22 pages with
commercials
and the hour is 42 with commercials
you know it's like that strict kind of
thing which they go
no it's it's 65 oh
70 minutes you know because
you're just watching the thing right so
so there's
there's a resolution within each episode
but then there's a through line that
it's going to continue
yeah okay unless it's the final unless
it's just a one-off
i mean sorry a movie yeah yeah
absolutely
but i still think it it still does
follow the same a b and c
you know first second third act wrap it
up type of thing
even within that one yeah yeah 30 40
minute
serialized because essentially we
you know you sit there for some movies
out now or
almost three hours so you know they
it was reading about we only we've been
trained into watching movies and we
start to
if you start to shift you know you know
it's
the attention span too sure because you
know
if it's if it's engaging i'll sit there
for three hours and forget it is
you know
well some movie theaters have
comfortable chairs yes i will say it's
true yes they've changed
a lot somewhere you're in an amazing
recliner
yeah you could fall asleep you know sure
i missed that middle hour it didn't
matter
and then others are like it feels like
it's you know at
a family barbecue and somebody got a
but if it's engaging i think if a movie
like you were saying how do you capture
the if it's engaging
i'll watch a three-hour movie and i'll
just be like wow that was three hours
you captured my attention but other
times if you're shifting
and this is too long you know this is
like or you're just like what's going on
let's wrap this as a self-indulgent you
know
yeah you know it's interesting when you
sit next to someone or near someone
that's enjoying a
film i feel like it's contagious yes and
then the opposite
right if they're fidgety or they're you
know or there's like this family drama
going around and they're changing
scenes right yeah what are you doing you
know the movies season you're living
no and i've seen that and then i've
actually moved and i sat next to a woman
who loved the film and it was great and
we were both laughing at the same parts
never saw her again but it was enjoyable
yesterday that collective
energy where you go opening night and
you know that energy of like everybody's
there to
be entertained you know and you can feel
it it's almost palpable you know
yeah yeah in the same way you're talking
about where people like
you know taking phone calls in the
aisles and yeah
or the phone lights up and you're like
oh my gosh you just ruined the thing for
me i'm a purist i have to when i go in
there's no talking
absolutely i went with a friend and i'd
never been to the movies with him
and uh i didn't realize he was the worst
person in the world to go to a movie
with
and we're watching and they think it was
some action movie
and oh it's uh and he turns to me and i
see him
on the corner of my eye and i don't want
to look at him like
and he i'm like what he goes oh my gosh
he goes
that was so crazy it would never happen
but you believe it right and i'm like
why are you talking to me
so i put him on the list never to see a
movie with him again
you know it's scary because now i go
alone i'm like i don't want anybody you
know
before the trailers it's very important
because that's that's the
um i say it's the the church of cinema
you know you're going in for the the one
time you're probably gonna see it
and that first time is so important how
how you feel
and you know you see a movie successive
times and it could be
one of your favorites but i don't want
to be interrupted i want to have my own
thing
you know and a lot of times now it's
just it's it's hard
even when you go on off times you're
like don't you people have jobs it's
like the movie's
you know filled at noon so you know it's
like isn't everybody working
you know i like to see movies with
people i do too but not when they're on
their phones and i've definitely seen
i've witnessed some major arguments
during the movie
but it's more yeah if you go to the
theaters like the cinema tech
there's going to be a different type of
you know fan
moviegoer there because they'll respect
the process i found that
hopefully hopefully you're right yeah
but you're like okay
with the munching and the thing and the
swirling of the coke you know right back
here
that's happened too with the big gulp
you know i'm like or the picnic lunch
that was brought in one time
yeah the whole theatre is empty i go
great i'm gonna see this movie alone
and a couple come in with their picnic
and they sit down i'm in the middle of
theater empty they sit down right in
front of me of course
crinkle crinkle crinkle you want this
and i start smelling like smells i'm
like
you know foods not popcorn like you know
food
meats barbecue yeah but i'm like oh my
gosh crinkle crinkle
you had to sit right in front of me huh
sure of course because it's the
collective yeah yeah
so that part of uh that's what shies me
away from going to the theater you know
yeah well i had a woman that wanted me
to clean her seat because it was dirty
and i said well maybe we could just look
at this
anyway we won't work
we still love going to the movies i do i
love it i love it
when you see it with the right audience
and they're enthusiastic and they're
respectful
it's fantastic sometimes you walk out
and you're
you know ah it resonates with you and
you just want to go home and write a
fantastic movie like you've seen you
know that's
that's when it's magic sure you know and
that that happens every so often
or you have the rare conversation with
the total stranger sure about the
subject matter
sure and it's and and you see in that
moment how powerful
just that experience was sure with all
these strangers in a darkened theater
and you're like wow we don't even know
each other but we're here for
i don't say church but you know it's a
similar thing it really is we're all
coming into
this is where the movie was meant to be
seen not on your phone
no i didn't shoot it in 70 millimeter
for you to you know go on a rail stop
and go that's great you know
so we can watch it how we want but it's
you know
it's nice when you you see the pure
cinema that was meant to be
you know from its intent rather than
you know it's become movies have become
just another thing now
you know it's a disposable like oh yeah
it's another form of movies used to be
the only thing
you know and then television came in but
then they had to compete so we got to
make bigger
you know widescreen and keep all that
but now there's so much stuff
video game there's so much noise and
things to distract you that it's just
it's another thing people used to dress
up to go to movies i mean dress up like
with tuxedos like
it was a night out to be you know
we're going to the movies uh you know
more people went to the movies like in
the 40s and
50s than they do today the depression
yeah
yeah yeah yeah and and i i love that
people want to be there and i love to be
in a in a crowd
of truth popcorn smell the anticipation
you know the greatest childhood memories
are
going in that movie theater the lights
come down and you know the logo
you know then there's star wars you're
like oh and it takes you away to this
galaxy and you're like
oh man i want to do that you know how do
i create stories you know how do i
that's fantastic i want to be a
filmmaker you know that's the greatest
memories of being a kid is going
to see that and being influenced by
movies
sure i can still see e.t yes
what are the top three mistakes a new
screenwriter is likely to make
on their first screenplay big one i
think number one is overwriting
not knowing what to put in what to leave
out so the script is
you know big speeches and things it can
be cleaned up as long as you know that
it has to be cleaned up in the second
draft you know i mean
hopefully there will be knowledge to
know that uh
number two not proof reading the script
you know typos
and also format issues um
which maybe format would be the third
thing you know
separate those typos basically
not being you know people get excited
about finishing something
and you have to keep it close until it
really is worth
having someone read it because you know
it's a big problem if
if uh you know it's going to represent
you
and if it's not in a good shape you know
it's not
in a proper form to be read then
you won't get a second read or that
person
you know will look upon you and say you
know the writer is not
good how does a writer determine their
strengths
and weaknesses good question a lot of
times a writer's strength
um could you know i was thinking back to
writing partners
uh which i had at one time for a number
of years
and what our strengths were and my
partner's strength was coming up with
the idea
he would have a dream and say i have a
coffee in the morning
i just i have our next movie and i would
be
that wouldn't be such a strength of mine
because i'm very picky about ideas and
you know they they come few and far
between for me not you know some people
are like
everything's an idea for a movie it kind
of isn't you have to work more at some
and others are definitely not you know
just boom
so his strength was coming up with the
idea
my strength was actually for us to be
able to sit down
and write the idea you know structure
all this kind of thing so and he knew as
well but i was the one at the keyboard
you know and so sometimes a writer also
can have a strength
of dialogue so let's say a partner is
like
really good with dialogue and the
other's good with structure or both of
them are good at both
you know but uh i think when you
the more that you write and find what
your strength
and weaknesses are will be from what
notes you receive you know over time and
time again like well
structure wise this is off and that your
dialogue's great
uh your character's in you know what i
mean so
i think you can only find out what your
strengths or weaknesses by
doing it and then when you find a
weakness
try to build upon that and get better
you know maybe make it a strength
sure so it's only by um getting feedback
and if you don't have a writing partner
sending it out for notes having sure
a friend yeah or writer's groups or a
consultant or someone to read it
and you know these things it takes time
of course and from let's say you write a
first script you're not going to have
any idea what your
your strength is that you got to page
100 you know
and you may have all the strengths uh
possible but you also
everybody has a weakness that has to be
built upon you know i mean to be
to be uh to have it all be up at the
same level so what you want to do is
calibrate that and it comes
it'll take time but also like you said
it'll take i think from feedback
because you'll see time and time again
what um what am i not doing right what's
what's not hitting the mark
you know well your dialogue still isn't
it all sounds the same
you know i'm kind of weak at dialogue
but i can really craft a great structure
you know type of thing so i think after
um two or three or more scripts maybe
you start to
say well i should really study dialogue
more you know like we were talking about
record it and be out in the world listen
to
how you know inflections tone
diction things like that so yeah i'm
always shocked at how in i mean
personal conversations like on people's
cell phones
it's i mean i guess you could get some
incredible stories from them i'm always
surprised that people are willing to
share such personal information oh sure
of course space
and you only hear the one side yeah and
i've heard some doozies
in my time just being in a store and
like oh my goodness
like right this person has either they
don't care the text came back
yeah i've heard all sorts of stuff you
know
and so yeah and you can only imagine
what's being said on that other side
that's great you know
which is a technique you know like in
the scene too where it's like
we don't you know we we can only know
what's on this side and in our mind
you know type that's true yeah yeah
because it keeps like i'm
thinking who who is this other person on
the right
and usually it's someone that's not
doing a lot of talking
sure or they don't say hi honey or you
know it's
a you know what's going on here right
you know with that you would say
well that's like good i love how
everybody says that's a good idea for a
movie
you go it's not what is it you know it's
like okay it's a kernel
which could be built but what is it
about you know what do we you know or
someone comes to your party and says
hey you write scripts don't you yeah
when i can and they go i got a good idea
for a movie you're like great i say
you should write it they go i'm not a
writer i said well
i'm you want me to write your idea they
say yeah it's great and then they pitch
it to you and you go
yeah okay i'll think about it and not to
sometimes you know
but it's like every idea is an idea for
a movie
you know if it's worked on yeah and
sometimes like like we were talking
about
you beat the dead horse and you walk
away you're like it's not you know
forgive me for this question what's the
stupidest way to write a screenplay
well you're talking to someone who's a
big fan of the outline so i would say
and not that the person who does it is
stupid
but those are my words not yours yeah
your words my words
uh send the letters and cards yeah
they know the email it would be just to
sit down and say i got an idea
a half-baked idea that really wasn't
thought out
and you can do what you want which is
fine but i just think you know
and you may find there's a scene in
there that's great and brilliant but
a cohesive through line and all that it
takes time it takes
it takes work you know um
this isn't something that just spills
out some people say i can just spill a
script out
in a week well that's fantastic and and
we'll see how good it is and maybe you
can do that
everybody's got their own way but uh
there are a lot of pitfalls in in that
in doing that you know with the story
and things aren't working and
it's just it's i hate when i sit there
and i write something and i know it's
just bad
i the best times and you know we all go
through that but the best times are
where
it's i'm it's like this weird uh
channeling and i can almost i can see it
in my mind's eye and that's going on to
the page
and i feel good about it because it's
like i watched
it i already watched it in the theater
but it hasn't existed yet except in my
head
going to so it's in a way when when it's
really good it feels like you're
channeling it
and when it's bad there's something the
channel is not
those waves are not coming through not
to be like you know oh
you know you're all done you age yeah
dial up versus sure
your own you're tapping into your your
creative
um thing your well whatever you want to
call it where you go
and it's it's it's you know the signal
is not
and you just write down a scene you're
like that's going to have to be
rewritten
you know imagine now you probably
person probably wouldn't think that just
burning through a script oh this is
great oh you know
but you you when it's just bad and
you're like that
oh my god it's garbage it's terrible
like a placeholder
instead of the real scene you know yeah
okay well this is just
this is the bad version as everyone says
you know you get that note from people
say well
um here's the bad version and they tell
you and you're like
that's really not that bad but you know
no no i don't want you to do that but
here's an example of what not to do
you know the bad version as as you hear
in hollywood a lot
and i'm like are you ever going to tell
me the good version
and they said no that's for you to
figure out oh you're right
you're right i cuz i'm the writer right
throw me a lifeline here you know
i'm drowning because i got the bad
version that's the real bad version
is this sunset boulevard yeah exactly
yeah
yeah is it almost similar to the people
that in college said
i don't have to study i just show up for
tests in a way
and there's some that can i've never met
any
but um yeah i
especially especially with the i think
with the
um with the odds that there's so many
scripts out there
and so many good scripts too that
i think a lot of times writers don't
may not see the mountain that they're
climbing every day or what they're
you know you're not only up against your
own competing with yourself you know to
be a better writer
next time and next time and learn like
you should
uh but also what's actually out there if
you want to work in the marketplace type
of thing and i know when you say that
when i say that it sounds very
non-romantic
you know but it's a business
you know so why not put your best foot
forward in creating that
you know unless you have no um if you
have a good day job and there's no
pressure you know to to that this script
has to sell
you know to make your rent or your
mortgage payment and you're just like
yeah i'll dabble in it
but dabbling takes time as well and so
you know while you're dabbling another
person
is working 24 hours a day and learning
the craft and really you know patch they
want it more than anything else
and it can be a hobby it's fine
you know but i think there are ways to
approach a career or a writing career
in a certain way and people can try it
however they want but the
this your back to your original question
is just to go i think i have an idea
and not really whoa you know hold on a
second you know
what are you doing here with this idea
you know every idea is a kernel
of a premise that builds now but do we
have enough
is you know type of thing and that's a
second guess like what's selling if it's
really a passion idea you want to write
absolutely go you know you must do it
but you also yeah
and what about people that say well
i don't want to write for tv or i don't
want to write a movie that
doesn't have a-list talent in it and
they they stomp on something
because it's not star wars sure
what do you say to that they want to be
a screenwriter they want to work in the
industry
but oh no that's not
that's not 48 hours or you know i'll
pick more there's some
movies sorry let me pick something in
the
last few decades um no i know what you
mean right okay it's not it's
but you're saying they stomp on the the
smaller ideas
yes i i read a lot of uh scripts that
are big
big ideas you know big hollywood ideas
which is fantastic
but the real odds of an unknown
uncredited writer
it could happen it does once in a great
not as much as it used to in the past
you know
selling that thing that's the only thing
they've written
because intellectual property ip is all
the
the rage you know it's already been a
book it's been you know a comic book
it's been it's been a sequel a prequel
you know star wars is a perfect example
we just we just manufacture until the
end
and then we come up with a new series
right that's all done we'll veer off on
this one and we'll take that character
and we'll
make a whole series on that one um
that's a bigger
that you're trying to you're trying to
hit a home run
out of the park which we all do all the
time
but you're i think you're also shrinking
your your possibility because
they already have the a-list writers out
there you know who are filling those
jobs
and how does how do they get there well
i don't know everybody has their own
journey
if you trace um i was saying a writer
who's a big tv person now and features
started on xena princess warrior now
people would look down and go
xena that's a ridiculous uh you know
blah blah
everybody starts somewhere and was it
his heart's desire to
work on that show forever no but that
was a
stepping ground and everybody has that
stepping ground you just don't
my experience and the people i've known
you just don't start out
at the top you know you take the job
and you go yeah okay it's not my perfect
thing but all
now i'll do it's a step-by-step process
so
um i would say in that way don't step on
those little ideas
because those are the ones that can be
made
you're taking a bigger gamble writing
this hundred million dollar script
that's locked into that budget
you know can't be made for less so then
you say well where can it's be made
i don't know there's four studios that
could possibly do this
let's say they all pass were you gonna
go with the script
somebody's gonna shell out a hundred
million dollars of their own money i
mean you know what i mean
so the smaller idea
um smaller in scope meaning you know
we're not out to save the universe the
universe could be your own life
you know your your little universe uh
could actually be made
five million dollars two you know it's
not
it's not um glamorous like like a lot of
writer well i'll just sell my script for
millions of dollars and
and you think that your life changes
overnight you still have the same
problems
you still have the same relationship you
still have you're still a person it's
just
it's job you know what i mean it's sort
of and i hate to sort of
shrink it down to that but but it's like
oh a screenwriter yeah i used to think
the same way too in film school oh my
god
you know you read the trades you're like
oh he's i'm gonna live the life
live the life yeah you're gonna be
living the life at two in the morning
writing the screenplay that's what it is
it's work it's not glamour
there's times when uh you're forgotten
about it a screening
happened where they thank everybody yeah
bling bang
and then they thank the craft service
and then they go let's run the film
and you're sitting with the stars and
they look at you and you're mortified
you're like
and then afterwards of course it was it
was just a
it was an oversight and at the party it
was like oh my god i'm so sorry
have another martini you know i'll call
you yeah
wow wasn't that bad but it was just you
know what i mean it's not all going to
be
uh and if you're in it for that fame and
fortune and
fanfare not the writer
i mean we've made inroads a little more
than the past
but it's still you know you're still the
writer i mean it sounds
it's the most one of the most important
people because that's where
without the scripts is they say there's
nothing right but
you know that's why you should like try
to be a hyphen writer producer
you know writer director or something
like that eventually i mean
or start out as that that's your that's
your choice
you know that's your career direction
but just the writer
it's you know it's an interesting road
what's the difference between a
professional level script and one that's
written by an
amateur professional level script can
i would say compete in the professional
marketplace
where someone could receive a screenplay
and read it and not go
hmm this has too many problems that this
person probably isn't
they're not writing at a professional
level meaning that somebody would say oh
my gosh
this we we could make this you know it's
not plagued with the problems i think we
spoke about before about
you know the the first time overwriting
the script and
and you know the structure doesn't
really work and i don't it's confusing
and it's not fulfilling the ending
doesn't wrap it up you know things
if you were to read that and and also
as we mentioned before format too you
know you look at the script and
if it's all over the place where it's
kind of clunky and weird and like i've
never
what is it's going to be it's not
professionally written
professionally written um
how soon into reading a screenplay do
you know that it's bad
well it's uh it's usually in the
beginning
but many times you're fooled because the
beginning is easy to set up so you're
like oh this is great and then the
longer
it goes on it runs out of steam
and then it just really is like okay
or or that it's it's too long
it's like too many pages and there's a
whole nother
story and a half there that that shows
that should needs to be
have a lot of editing you know for in
if it was a first draft it's a script
and a half almost you know a script in a
third let's say
which is overwriting um
so so then a
reader will know fairly quickly a reader
uh
will probably know uh in the first page
or two
if if it's the format giveaway or it's
just
the style giveaway where it's
you know what i mean you can tell i mean
people all the time post
one page on the internet you know they
put up a page of their script and you
can see it and go
okay you know you can it's a giveaway
it's clear giveaway um or you can see
another
page and go wow you know it's it's so
clear
like you're seeing what they meant to
you know like you're seeing what they're
writing not
it bump and i was that who got out of
the car
and you know oh oh you know
and that goes back to you know in a way
it goes back to format and how
you know what you're going to put in or
what you're not based upon the story
what do you think about 99 percent of
screenplays being
rejected after the first page um i don't
know if
there were well i i think they would be
read
they're not thrown in the garbage after
page one i think a script is given a
chance
i mean i would hope you know from a
reader and
then it's the overall feeling of it but
like we were discussing before if
there's too many bumps and you know the
famous thing is oh this bumps for me you
know it's like
it bumps okay it means
i mean i know what they mean but it's
probably like boom you know it sort of
bumped in and not a good way where they
it was confusing or the story was like
why did it go that way and i didn't
understand it was this and that
and a lot of times sadly it's because of
skimming you know where someone
just literally you know i read one
time that some people just read the
dialogue or some producer just reads
dialogue he doesn't read the
directions just reads the dialogue you
know i don't know
what you know that's not really reading
the script but
um i think as we were discussing before
you can tell in the first few pages
if it's going to be one of those scripts
or if it's going to be like
wow this is a page turner i can already
see that you know it's hard to hide that
if you're not writing at a particular
level
i mean so that'll be a dead giveaway
which is not good
so you think though people give it more
than just a scene
oh sure oh you do yeah you know the old
adage is like well it doesn't happen
within the first 10 pages
it used to be the first 20 but now it's
shrunken down if it doesn't happen
you know if i'm reading and it doesn't
happen for me i you know you sort of
have to know what
we're getting into uh but again
these aren't rules not coming from me
i'm just saying
that some movies like you know european
films
take longer to happen and you know
i'm talking about hollywood if you want
to work in that system
you know it better happen the reader's
got to go
10 pages i still don't know what's
happening
you got to get an idea like oh we see
this and that you know i mean that's
what they're talking about is
is happening you know and they'll read
through the script no
but if you if you're plagued with typos
three or four page it means you don't
care enough to proofread your script
and you don't care about enough for the
person who's reading it's time
so right away there's a disrespect there
like well i just gotta i just wanted to
blow through it because
you know my idea is so good i don't have
to proof read the script
okay you know i mean these are these are
attitudes that um
won't serve you well in the long run
what are your thoughts on hollywood
stealing an unknown writer's idea
does this happen a lot i think i think
it happens a lot less than
people believe because like my old
writing partner and i used to say
we'd make more money off the lawsuit
than we would on the screenplay
you know go ahead and steal and you know
we'd be so pleasure it'd be such a
pleasure for you to steal our idea that
means it's something good you know
but uh you writers do a writer asked me
like okay um what's this process of
copyright you know
before i let anybody read it i was like
okay
you can copyright the script it takes a
process it's money and
you know or you can register at the
guild or you know
some say that even by the mere existence
of creating it is a copyright so there's
all sorts of factors but
what i've read is that the copyright
would protect you more in court
but the thing with that is that you
never own the copyright of a screenplay
because the minute
you sell it it becomes a work for hire
so you always have to sign over the
the rights to the company so that was
given away a long time ago
um in in guild negotiations that the
writer never owns a copy out of the
script
so you're it's okay to do that but
uh when you see uh on the cover it says
registered
wgaw number one two six five five by
five
you know that's just a dead giveaway of
like an amateur that's afraid of
of my stuff being stolen you know what i
mean
no no professional writes that on the on
the cover of a script
i think professionals expect you to do
your due diligence
and what i think more the more chance of
something being stolen is a pitch
because that's an ether you know like i
i was saying bef
uh my writing partner and i would go on
these
these pitch fest you know that their
agent would send us on
to like 12 companies and we'd do the
same pitch around town
and at two o'clock we've got with with
this person and
our manager would ask us agent manager
go how did it go
and we'd say well it didn't they didn't
know their eyes didn't light up they go
okay maybe you should switch and change
this element so from the afternoon on
we changed a different version of of the
thing but
my point is it's all a living breathing
thing and so somebody could wake up the
next morning and go
now they might not be the exact pitch
but they but let's say an element of and
go you know what i have an idea
and that works in what do you do about
that but you can't be
you can't be um that way where you think
everybody's gonna steal your stuff you
know it's just not
you can be smart and when you send out
your script you should keep
track in a log or journal uh
or spreadsheet who's reading the script
every time out if you don't have an
agent manager who that's their job
you know obviously they'll know that
it'll be through an official channel but
somebody says oh yeah give me the script
i work at a company okay that goes down
who read it when
because these are important things to
know who you don't want
to send your you know you want to know
who's reading it that's important too
because if it starts getting bad
feedback you never hear about it
and then suddenly things start being
like why why do i get a meeting with
that company
because people are talking now you know
the old days would go in a database and
there'd be coverage the studio would not
have the coverage you couldn't
you couldn't fool them because they go
oh yeah we read that
two years ago they're trying to pawn
that off on us again you know
so i wouldn't be too fearful of and
there was a few stories about outright
theft but i think it's so i mean
you can't be afraid to send your stuff
out you know
and and it's sort of an arrogant idea
where it's like well my idea is so
genius that they're going to steal it
like warner brothers doesn't have enough
amazing ideas already
and yours might be the one they steal
but it'd be a good lawsuit
but that being said though don't be
irresponsible sending it out the log the
date the place
absolutely the address even oh yeah no
keep it all because you want to you want
to keep track
of who's reading your stuff you want to
keep in control of that
and that's why when writers post their
stuff like a script up on their
their web page i would say
don't do that you don't know who's
reading it you don't know who's stealing
your ideas right
you have no way of tracking that if
you're if you're afraid of that
that's even worse because somebody's
just going to your website and i know
it's
it's a way to promote your stuff but
that's not the way
you know to have your full script on on
your your your website for someone just
to read who's reading it
you know that's you want to keep track
of that
what are the best ways to make people
read your script
well you could put a gun to their head
maybe a softer approach
yeah a softer approach um
well you have to ask who
what are we talking about industry
people or
friends people that could actually well
know people they could actually
have something done with it or get it to
an appropriate person
to have something have it made well
before that happens like we were
discussing before it had better be in a
professional
uh level of writing and also
presentation
execution and so when you get one chance
um like i would say you may have a
friend at a company that's
runs the company right and you go ivan
in there
okay that's great but when you're going
to play that hand of sending that script
over
you know it better be ready you know you
can't play that hand you should be
follow uh you know be very disciplined
and be patient
because sometimes people get excited
they want to play all the hands and it
wasn't the script you know and then now
it's like
i'm your friend but i also have a
business you know what i mean so
i just can't hire you i just can't buy
your movie
and it's going to be more difficult to
go back there um
again so um
you know you don't know if somebody's
going to like your script
you you have to like it and the way that
you make them like it is show that
you're passionate about what you're
writing
and that you've done all those things
like proofreading which sounds
simplistic but
it's important i mean it's offensive
when you you
i'm gonna take the time to you know you
open it up you're like
you know and you want to be a writer you
know you can't
you know there's spell check you know
there's
things like that your scripts are all
about the tiny details and those are
looked over
and so what what what attitude is the
person reading going to have of you
you know about being serious serious
meaning you want to be a professional
when you're writing a screenplay do you
ever think about the money you'll make
off of it
as you're writing it no because
i already have a contract so i know
now a spec yeah you can have illusions
of grandeur you know as much as you want
but after
years in the business you know the
realities of like okay but no you
shouldn't
you shouldn't write from a place of that
you should forget about all that like i
say you should do
your best job ever if you're paid 500
bucks or you're paid 5 million
bucks there should be no no difference
in
in your desire because then what are you
doing you're chasing money there's other
businesses to do that that are that are
far more lucrative
than spending you know years of your
life toiling away and trying to have
that one
this is the one that's going to do it
you know
so um no you should just bathe in the
creative process and not
you know it's when you're writing your
specs
when you're writing an assignment you
already have a contract you know what
you're making so
and then it becomes you know stressful
because you're actually making something
so you're like oh shoot this is due when
this better be good you know this is
what they're paying me for
so that comes at a different level you
know when you leap over into that
other realm of working like we discussed
earlier about um
being creative under a deadline than
just toiling away
you can work it's great to work when you
want you know
you know my spec i'm just doing you know
this and there's no nobody else
not working with anybody else this is
all my words
which it has to be to get to a certain
point absolutely
but then you step over that line into
the other world
and it's like well we don't like the
ending and then the number
and it becomes you know like they say
filmmaking is a million
um compromises to get something done and
sadly yeah but to get something done is
amazing
and does that go back to what we're
talking about with the tai chi
or the the karate example which is
part of it's the physical and part of
it's the mental and maybe that pressure
of like
i've got to be creative and i've got a
deadline and
not not cracking under that pressure
sure
it's uh a lot of it i mean tremendous
amount of is mental
you know but then those disciplines you
can fall back on on
not straight because you can get into
this terrible wheel
that you're not producing at the best
level you can because you're too worried
about
the other thing if you just trust
yourself and
dive into the work you'll get it done
you know if you're not constantly
worried about well i got eight days left
you know just do it how important is
sticking to
one genre for a new screenwriter i
personally think it's
you you eventually have to find what you
know what you like to write
and some people um say well i like to
write horror i like to write drama
romantic comedy and that's great
uh i'm not sure many people are good at
all of that you know
you sort of gravitate toward what what
you dig you know it's like what
what i really liked what movies do i
like and some people like i only like
romantic comedies okay and some are like
i could not write a romantic comedy
so don't write what you don't like
basically i think william goldman said
it
don't write annie hall if you don't like
romantic comedies
it's pretty simple but you have to test
those first scripts or that's what
they're for is to try to
figure it out like wow i don't like
action movies you know i mean
to write them it's kind of follows this
thing and that and
now if you write drama you know a lot of
most popular movies are hybrid they're
not just one thing
you know they're um supernatural sci-fi
horror you know if you you can find
those different elements those are the
most popular films
that don't just stick to one thing you
can you can find
multiple uh genres within this you know
sub genres in the in the one genre
but generally the the first thing that
you sell
is probably going to be the thing you're
going to work at
because that's what they're going to
sort of pigeonhole you
and know you as a blah blah oh you write
drama
so when the agent or managers are
sending you out they're not going to
send you to the
romantic comedy people because you're
not a comedy writer and you say well i
can
i can write comedy um you know what i
mean
so but i think you have to find your way
and and not to say you have to stick to
one genre you could be good
in many but um just know that the first
thing you sell
is probably gonna chart your
the way that you're going you know
because you always hear that about
actors that they seem to get the same
roles
because hollywood likes to kind of
pigeonhole you right they like yeah but
they work all the time
so i say pigeonholing not a bad thing
you know if you
if you want to work you know you say
well i want to break out of that and
some do
you know some do character actors you
know great because
but yeah i think those first specs are
ones to figure out
to find your way unless you really know
i like these movies you know i only
write these i'm not interested and you
can whittle it down but you can also
see that you might write a hybrid you
know supernatural horror movie
or something like that you know where
you've got two genres mixed
mixed together but i don't think if you
sell that
and it does well they're going to say
hey we're going to hire you for a comedy
next
and yeah really do you do comedy
unless you have one but would you be
working on that simultaneously
you know i always think writers writers
can write
you know in the old days in the studio
they would have you on a noir
and then next week you'd be on a western
you know when they have the stable of
writers like in sunset boulevard you
know and so they would write all
different kind of movies
you know they have the the freedom and
ability to do that and then they're
today they're auteurs who are known for
one type of thing which is great
if you can be that you know if you're
the working screenwriter
you may fall into a place where you
start to work in a genre
and you're like wow i didn't realize
that was my genre now not bad it's okay
you know what's the biggest
screenwriting pitch
you've ever gone out on and what
happened
yeah there was a pitch
that i had with my writing partner we
had a lot of pitches um
one solo i've been on that haven't been
like you know oh my god this is with
it's been with you know heads of
television or whatever but
i specifically remember one pitch we did
and
the head of the company was there the
whole strata of people
were there the assistant the vp and
we went on for way too long i mean it
was absurd how long the pitch was
they basically told us we saw the whole
movie
you know it was like a 20-minute pitch
and no one stopped us and we were crazy
enough to rather than make it five
minutes or oh and
you know and we walked out of there and
our manager said they're gonna
they're gonna buy this and blah blah
blah it was just like oh my god
and uh something happened where it
wasn't
it never materialized but um there was
another pitch it wasn't big but
the the guy made us wait
and he was late and then we're sitting
in the lobby and we see him
in the office and he sees us and he like
pulls the blinds and we're like i know
that's a good sign and i hadn't we had
been around and i hadn't had lunch and i
was like freaking out i was like i gotta
eat something so i went in their pantry
and i was like ripping open bags of
cookies and stuff and
oj i got to get my blood sugar up you
know and then he comes out hey
and he walks us into his room and we're
like okay he's back in our you know
and we sit down and what do you got for
me
and we go well here we go and we always
would pitch where um
my partner was like p.t barnum you know
and i would fill in the blanks here and
there
we start to pitch and about 30 seconds
into it he stopped
oh stop stop stop stop he goes
it's it's it's crap because it's just i
don't believe any of it
and we're like he's joking you know of
course he is right he was serious
and we both look at each other mortified
and we're like wow that's never happened
and then he uh came around from the desk
you know and leaned on the desk and said
okay here's the thing
i got an idea from my nephew and he sent
me a 10-page email and now he's pitching
us and i've never had it where where
ever i mean all the pictures of my
entire life
so you never know but they always let
you finish i mean they'll interrupt you
but they'll let you finish the pitch he
cut us off at the knees and then he
pitched us
he twisted around and you think well
okay um
maybe that'll be our idea and he says
what do you think and we're like i don't
know what to think i think
we got to get out of here you know so we
both left
and um he rode the elevator down with us
oh wow
he said you need validation i said i was
hoping it was from you
but yeah i need it for the 18
to park you know because you were late
45 minutes with your other meeting
uh cookies were great in the pantry but
that doesn't you know
so uh he said all right you know go off
and blah blah and we never saw him again
but so you never know pitching is a
really mixed bag and i've also been on
a pitch at a big production company with
the heads of television
and they i mean it was out of body
experience i mean i was almost sitting
like
who is this guy i mean i was sitting
like next to myself watching it
because i and they were late which many
times
you know they'll make you wait you're
not just like the doctor's office you're
like it was for 11 30.
they're like i know but it's 12 and
i'm sorry i'm sorry you know would you
like some water no i'd like scotch
please
excuse me and then you begin
and that was on you know sometimes you
know you're just
on and you can see it and the questions
that they ask
are at the end which is great they don't
interrupt you in the middle
and then your train of thought you're
like uh you know and you're
you know then the questions were just um
what city do you see this happening they
weren't like i didn't get the part about
the thing and you're like oh no you know
because you practice your pitch
backwards forwards before you go and
it's it's a lot of it's improv too
you know what i mean and you have to
leave those spaces open for them to go
could it be a thing
yeah yeah that's great i love that oh my
gosh you've made it that much better
yeah
yeah but you have to leave it open for
it to go
you know certain ways and i left and
they were like thank you very much
and i called my manager and she was like
oh my god i wish i could have been there
and seen that i said it was
it was high it was it was a great high
walking out of there now they didn't buy
it but
i pitched at a professional level
where that door is completely open so
it's not like
who that yeah you know what i mean
so you never know you're just talking
about pitching it's a mixed bag but you
have to
it really helps to have a writing
partner you know when you when you both
go in
except the one guy we wanted to like
flip his desk over and go what and break
the windows and say
you know he turned the tables on us for
sure
so when you leave a situation like the
one that you just mentioned not not the
one where you've you've had an outer
body experience
almost but oh the bad one the bad one
yeah how are you
regrouping like how are you saying well
at that time we went back to our
handler you know and said oh my gosh and
this is like ridiculous we had such good
pitches during the day and that one was
just off
from another planet i don't know what
happened there and um
you know you don't let it rattle you too
much you got to move on and that's not
the end-all be-all
it was just a freaky deaky situation
you know you don't want all of them to
be like that
sure i remember another pitch um the
person was like you know
almost falling asleep and that's not
good either
but you're like at least you could hide
that you know i know you don't like it
but
and then the minute that we finished
you know she got up and said well thank
you very much for coming in you're like
this is
was just a waste of time everybody you
know
maybe you could tell like they can you
know you can read and another one's like
oh
my uh there's one at a studio there were
like diapers around the office so i my
nanny usually has the kid but i had to
there's like a little we're like yeah
don't be distracted we're only trying to
you know pitch for our lives here you
know
it's always like you never know
when you come off of one that was like
magical
sure how soon are you finding out
they're telling you it's a pass right
away
uh usually they get back to your agent
or manager
right you know shortly thereafter it's
not like weeks after no and then they
say yeah you know we
we really like uh what was going to buy
it i mean out of
sometimes they buy it in the room you
know it happens but
but more importantly about that is that
you you show that you have ideas
that you that you you know you have
cohesive ideas that can actually like we
were saying
what makes something a tv show well you
can pitch something they go yeah that's
like the stuff we do
you know and so it's on that level of
like oh it's convoluted it's all over
the place
it's not even a good pitch you know so
many holes in it that's what you don't
want
so you've done your homework before you
ever get there and then that keeps the
door open
and then of course you send a thank you
card which i always
say you know handwritten thank you card
after that
not an email to those people that you
met with because they'll get it a week
later and they'll
even if they pass they go oh mark yeah
you know what he because they're busy
with a million other pitches
you know 100 a week or whatever you know
and it's like oh yeah i really like mark
you know that one pitch was
was close and
the closer you get each time it's a
little closer and maybe
the close only is here for a while and
sometimes
the close has actually become something
you know
so even though you didn't get it's like
the one that got away
yeah it sounds like you still are left
with a feeling of
i almost got there rather than one where
it almost you feel
cheap yes when you leave like it's a bad
date
yeah and just like there was going to be
violence
i mean when the guy was like he came out
from around the desk and goes it's ah
yeah he's yelling at us we're like
we looked at each other like he's he's
got to be joking and he wasn't you know
it's one of those weird situations oh
yeah
whoo he's serious okay this
train wreck just went off is even worse
and now we're left with a
i don't know what we're left with you
know but
what gets you into the pitch is your
project so they have to read something
right so they read something they go oh
wow this is a great pilot do you have
anything else i get this other idea i've
got two other ideas
come on in you know it's the round
robins when you try to there you
get those fans of your writing you want
that
at a lot of different places so that
they can be that door's open
what else do you have that's why i say
for writers that you must have a lot of
material you know a solid body of work
that you've worked on that's at a
professional level
because that script will get you in that
company and then they'll listen to your
pitch and then they'll say
we passed but they won't say in the room
they pass but
they tell your handler and they say what
else does mark have
that's similar well he's got another
thing oh we'll send it right over so
there's your next chance now
who knows if it'll sell or not but you
keep that you can see how you can burn
out stuff quickly too
but you need that constant
um uh wheel you know turning of creating
material
you know not just the one script because
the one script could be a one-off where
they go this is fantastic
you got anything else that you've
written well i'm working on something
and i'll be done in six months
well we'll see ya i won't be here i'll
be fired i'm the executive you know
but whoever's here maybe will answer
your call or won't and
you know so you have to keep that
constant and it would take two or three
scripts i think
whether tv or features you know and if
you have a little accolade like whoa i
almost placed in a contest or something
oh great you know
rather than i'm just another writer here
with a script
please buy it you know
did you get any of those you said you
got them through an agent because you
had a handler
yeah agent and a manager well at that
time just a manager
what do you think about when you're
creating a protagonist
versus an antagonist trying to make a
protagonist
um you know you you can fear on the side
of
maybe they're right at the edge of being
bad
you know bottom line complex that's the
key
you know it can't be just a one note uh
character
and many different facets and with those
then you know you can almost help
create the story out of out of that
because you know this is that person's
past or you know this is why they are
feeling that way or this is what they
need you know this is their desire
they're trying to find
something you know on their journey that
they have to fulfill
and at the end hopefully they do maybe
they won't you know type of thing
uh but bait also somebody that we want
to follow
you know so hopefully you look at the
best characters in cinema and you're
like well you know
i i like them you know i like i want to
spend time
and i want to champion their cause you
know type of thing so
um and maybe i could see a little bit of
myself in that in their journey
as well
what about for the antagonists well they
the typical villain you know can't be
too um
cookie cutter either you know sometimes
you see it's just like they're all bad
you know they have to be you have to
also in a way understand like
joker you know if you understand
not do you have to like them but they
just can't come from like
that out of hell crazy place and just
they're all evil all stems from
something is it their childhood is it
the way something happened you know that
that
that helps to be like oh it's a more
believable um
uh character you know to go up against
and when um the antagonist push is too
much
the protagonist then they have to
somehow act
you know like well well well am i okay
it's it's go time you know and that that
they feed on each other
and sometimes you know the bad guy at
the end has
redemption you know and says i was bad
you know
type of thing make it make it
interesting you know turns around
doesn't mean that
you forgive them but you know on their
last breath
i'm sorry you know or something i don't
know
and does the good guy always have to win
for the story to be fulfilling
i don't think so i mean sometimes people
i i know that's a way when someone would
see it maybe go ah i wanted you know but
you know life's not always that way
it's it's more in the gray area where
you know
there's temptation and and um i think
those are the most interesting
characters that
it's not the white knight you know it's
it's the wow that's
you know that's different you know and
uh
i don't know if you can think of a
commercial film where the
where that's happened i'm not sure um oh
where the where the good guy doesn't win
yeah um yeah commercial commercial i
would think tender would want that
sort of hollywood ending type thing you
know but i think films more
today you know like the bad guy can
uh the bad character that can get away
with it and you're like that's not right
well not everything is fair you know
did you see richard jewell no not yet
okay yeah i was gonna bring that up
um well once upon a time in hollywood
sure some of the characters i don't want
to you're right
yeah some of the characters didn't have
a happy ending
but um sure yeah yeah but yeah that's
based on a real life you know stories
right parts of it are i know yeah but
you're right yeah hollywood ending i
don't know
that's why i would say we go back to
that point about the big movie
if you're writing that big hundred
million dollar film
do you think you could have where
you know the the protagonist hero
doesn't
win i mean maybe if there's a sequel um
uh but if you wrote the smaller
film you know be more i'd say unique but
you know what i mean
you could work maybe you could stretch
your
stretch it out a bit more to make it
more interesting you know you and you
would have the um
the ability to do that in that world
that's true and i think
art house audiences will be more
forgiving
oh sure if the quote-unquote bag or good
guy doesn't
sure right off into the sunset whereas
yeah well you know the noir is the the
poor sap that ends up
you know it's just that's why one of my
friends i hate those movies i'm like
yeah you know sunset boulevard he's not
gonna end well for him i'm sorry but
that's
we know in the beginning though it's not
gonna end yeah but that's
uh i like those movies because that's um
the world's not always you know there's
there's
injustice and never gets in you're like
that's
how do you d you know so those are
interesting
ones yeah what's the most amount of time
you spent on a screenplay
the most amount of time um
boy those are years ago not a lot of
time now but
um i think it would be
my fifth spec
and only because i stopped on page 60
and that was because of a personal uh
tragedy
and i didn't know if i was going to be
able to go back to it because i felt
guilty
about not
going through my grief some someone
passed away
and it took me probably six or eight
months
of stopped on page 60 to go back and
finish that first draft so i had good
momentum and then it was just
you know i was knocked out um
and just couldn't focus but
that experience uh worked its way into
the script
because there was loss in the screenplay
as well um
so it was really um
you know really found its way in there
in in the success of you know drafts
after that not in the first obviously
because it was only 60 pages but
it was you know upon
the other drafts it really you know so
that i think that would have taken the
longest time but
i don't you know from writing
assignments because there there's a
schedule
i really like to get a script done
you know in in in obviously the time
that the contract states but
just as in my own spec too i don't want
to work on it for years
you know i want to have something
available and do successive drafts
and then have something to be like okay
this is the one that at least
that i can show people so i would say
um you know three pages a day is a
feature in a month
easy it's very doable
um and people say oh i worked on a
script for a year
and again you can work on it for a long
time
without doing pages you know i mean
because you're doing the research
you're doing you know all these other
things to get to that point that could
take time as well you could spend
months uh that particular script i did
spend months of research before i even
started you know because it was a dream
so i had this little
like we was talking about all i had was
it was a little
like a little scene and i was like well
that's interesting but what like e.t
what about if someone was left behind
and so
started building out characters and
story and you know it was historical
movies so there had to be some research
done
so you know it's not always like oh
write the script in a month it could
take like the iceberg there's a lot of
work
that has under the surface that has to
be done so
um i don't know if i've answered your
question when you finished the one
uh screenplay where you stopped the 60
pages yeah something
bad happened yeah and then there was
this guilt how did you feel
once you finished that screenplay
because you said you took some of that
emotion
and put it in well i um i
felt it was almost um
that it was almost a uh a mission
you know to finish it because uh
the person would have wanted me to do
that and so that helped me get through
the guilt of like well how could it be
writing this script you know when this
happened
and um somebody passed away
and uh so i thought you know
this person would want me to go back and
do that they wouldn't want me to
honestly waste my time but you know what
i mean on this
this thing and so that helped motivate
me to go
you're okay there's no guilt in
finishing this thing
you know so yeah because you never know
um
you know when you're writing your life
can get in the way
and does and you know it's this other
thing that you do and if it's your
vocation you know that you get paid to
do it
um you know you can't just toss it aside
and say oh well i mean you know stuff
stuff happens in life too sure um
but like we were talking about earlier
but using your personal experiences
you don't want to have to go through
that stuff but if you do
you know you tap into it you know use it
it's
real it's authentic you know it's
authenticity um
actors love that kind of stuff you know
and so writers should do
certain as well the script that you're
referring to wasn't that the first
screenplay that you sold
it was yeah it was a world war ii
picture called
remember april and uh it
bumped around town for a number of years
and uh it finally got optioned and made
so it was like seven years from the time
that i
wrote the first draft to uh first first
day of photography
and not like i say not every project
is that way and some never get made and
you never
like like we were talking about earlier
you never know the journey of a project
it could sit around for years on a shelf
and then someone discovers it
or it could sell tomorrow for big money
you know there's everything in between
so
yeah what did that experience teach you
because didn't you have a day job or you
had another job during that time when
you had to
yeah yeah oh absolutely um during those
seven years sure and i also wrote other
specs and um
uh you know the whole the whole gamut
uh what it taught me was that
you know if if you really believe in a
script you know
don't don't give up with it now you have
to see the writing on the wall but
this one it almost won the nickel
fellowship
and i say almost that year they picked
the top eight people
you know out of 3 500 you know to get
the fellowship and my script was in the
top 20.
so they actually called me and told me
that and i was like oh wow okay
and so from that i was you know i was
able to get some people to read it and
this and that
but the the personal connection i had at
the time
with this company that was just starting
was the way in it wasn't
from an agent it was is my own
networking
so that's also important that everyone
says oh i'm looking for an agent you
know and
your own networking i think is almost
more important
because it's the face to face i've got
you
and you know an agent
unless they're just starting doesn't
need a 25th client
in in the way now some agencies are
actually signing
with the writer's guild about you know
about
everybody had to fire their agent you
know who was in in
in the guild um and some agencies are
signing now to say okay we're going to
follow the
you know the rules um but
you should be networking you know that's
the most important thing is to have
because that wasn't sold by an agent it
was my own connection
into that company so that's that's what
i learned as well
where were you networking like what like
you don't have to name the place but was
it was
kind of an impact it was my friend's
friend
who was in the business so my friend had
said oh
my friend is an assistant to blah blah
and they were just starting a brand new
company they already had a company
cut two million years later that
assistant became president of that other
company
and then he went off and left to have
his own company so you see how
you know what i mean it moves on so
every assistant is not going to be an
assistant forever
you know they want to look at the
rolodex and and find that
amazing script to bring to their their
producer and say look what i found
and you want that script to be yours and
you want that assistant to be somebody
that you have
a contact with because they're going to
grow and move into producers and whatnot
you know and that assistant
because of that script then as president
of the company hired me again and again
and then when he went off to hire me
again you know so i mean
that's how you build that none of that
was from an agent or a manager
now they're great to have but
but i i see people i wrote my script i
got i got to get you know
it's like you should be out networking
you can't
you can't rely upon your career and give
it to somebody else
you're the one thinking about it 24
hours a day
you know like networking where
um you know around town like in
there's there's functions all the time
um isa international screenwriting
association has a final draft has them
stage 32 has them meetups get-togethers
things like that
uh so just
or or just be out you know like you're
saying in los angeles
you never know who you're going to run
into and then there's no there's no
studio gate there that says they're not
getting in
i mean seriously i mean my friend uh was
chatting up someone and they were
the assistant to one of the biggest
producers in town wow
now nothing happened but then we were
talking blah blah okay
but they could have said oh that's an
interesting story because they're
looking
for that interesting story right and
they want to be the one who brings it to
the monkey muck and says look what i
found now they have to read it first it
has to go through hoops but you know
i mean it has to go through um hurdles
but isn't that much better than you know
oh i'm uh struggling writer and i you
know
here's my stuff and the agent or agency
gets back to you six months later you
know i mean
though those can get you to different
levels absolutely necessary but
my point is don't think that's the
end-all be-all
those will come when you're ready that's
the thing they'll come when you're ready
they won't come when you just finish
your first screenplay and let's just
the most amazing thing you know and then
they already has bids on it
and stuff like that you know so don't
stress it by getting representation
right away
that only comes plus you have to be a
workhorse if an agent is going to take
you on
or manager they want to see that you're
working like okay you got this this is
good we need to work and
change you got another then what else
you working on you have to be
working not just the one script
throw in the ring and go am i done no
you're not done it's just the beginning
do you think desperation um scares a lot
of
would-be deals away yeah you
um dickinsen's a desperate writer a
million miles away when you're like
you know the best place to be is where
you don't need it where
your life doesn't uh rest upon
this 100 pages you know
uh that's you know that's where it's
and plus the desperation can work into
your writing too
you know so no it's and it's hard you
know
desperation and fear and those all
things you gotta you know you gotta
constantly
keep in check when you are selling a
screenplay
what are different types of deals you
may encounter
well there's the the option agreement
you know which is to shop the material
so they're not buying the script
i mean there's provisions for purchase
of it but it's an option which means
they have the rights for
let's say three to six months and
they can have you do work on it or
possibly somebody else but they're
they're optioning the rights and
you have to be uh i
say careful but it's gonna take it off
the market
you know obviously because they're
paying you now
my first my first script sale the spec
was optioned
three times in a row so i was doing all
the rewrites
which is good so they'd optioned it for
a number of uh for quite a while
six months at a time and this allows
them to
find financing and that may fall through
so they don't want to let the project go
and also have their imprint on it
you know what i mean so when it came
time to execute the option
that means they had to purchase the
script and that was all in
in the contract um so
and then there's also the um
the outright purchase of the screenplay
you know and then you're usually given
a chance to rewrite it uh one draft
and with notes you know with the polish
and then if it doesn't quite gel
then there's a provision for you to be
let go and somebody else can be brought
on
and then it's always every time it's a
step deal
so there's steps you know money to start
so when you read in the trades that the
scripts sold for a million dollars
they didn't hand over a million dollars
it's only if the movie gets made
does all the money get paid so it all
sounds great
but you know you get money up front to
start
and let's say you have to do the outline
or treatment you get money for that to
start and turn in so there's steps
then rewrites and so the first draft you
know if you're doing an assignment it's
the same thing
for money to write the first draft money
when you turn it in
so it all goes by steps and then there
are provisions in each step
for how long it takes to read it and
also how long
that you're given to to write it i mean
after you write it how long
that you know there's responsibilities
on both sides
your responsibility to write it and the
producer's responsibility to read it in
a timely fashion
so meaning that you know they can't go
away for six months and then suddenly
get back to you you know what i mean
so those are traditionally the type of
of working contracts
what do you wish you'd known before
starting down this screenwriting path
hmm i
wish i had known how difficult it would
be and how much of my life
would my choice not complaining would be
given up
for it and
wouldn't have it any other way i could
change a few things in the past but
that's only because of lack of
experience and knowledge that you have
now you can only look back and say ah
i would never have done that or boy did
i blow that opportunity
you know uh which in
in my book i i i have those um
kind of stories and also disciplines
about that
um and you know you never
even whatever level you get to you still
make mistakes and you still go well i
you know i shouldn't have done that or
you hopefully make fewer of them uh
but just to realize how i mean out of
film school
you know the spec was crazy money was
going for specs and we all thought we
would just you know
write a good spec and have a career you
know and some did
and but the
the amount of time it takes and how it
can affect your life
you know the pursuit of this uh
like i was thinking recently that i
don't know if i would
today if i was 11 years old that i would
go hmm
you know um basically i can't say
because i only have hindsight but i
don't know if i would pursue it today
um you know the business constantly
evolves and changes
and i always say wow i wish i had worked
in the 40s as a writer you know it would
have been you know
of course um like in the one movie
everybody's looking back at a different
era with romanticized oh the 40s weren't
it you should have been a writer in the
30s
the 30s well pretty much before then
movies weren't around you know the 20s
okay
but you know and then authors were the
big thing you know
so we always look back but the main
thing i think was
um which i tell writers today
you know this is going to be a long haul
you don't think it is for you i
i know it i know you don't you're going
to be different and you could be
but it's going to be a long haul it is
for everybody if you if you talk to
anybody and you know on
your videos that you interview everybody
everybody has a different story of how
they
and i don't like to say make it because
you never make it in my opinion
you're we're always looking for our next
job you know we are
as writers you're on a tv show the show
ends
you get residuals great but you got to
get your next gig you're always gigging
you're always looking for you know
unless you have your own production
company
and a funnel of money then you can call
all the shots but
you're always looking for your next job
so making it is
getting your next job and the first one
i always say is the hardest
but the second one's pretty pretty
difficult too and then your third
and then your fourth and fifth and
you're like oh wow
and they're not always in in sequence
meaning they don't
they don't always come right after each
other there are periods that are dry
and not for lack of trying it's just the
nature of the beast
of the business they'll be slow periods
and they'll be oh my gosh i've got so
much work i don't even know what to do
you know and everyone everyone's journey
is going to be different of how they
break in
and so i was saying earlier about
networking you know extremely important
about getting
getting those relationships and not and
and not just
being um you know oh
you're my contact i expect you to help
me be a good contact
help people out if you can you know i've
done it so many times when somebody i
see a guy
they didn't know i caught hey you better
call so and so they've gotta
they got the job now they say oh it's
because of you i go
no it's because of you but i just happen
to
see that opportunity and tell you about
it you know and people remember that
they remember completely for years and
years that you know my friend of mine
still
to this day says you got me five years
on a tv show i said that wasn't me he
goes no no
if you and he knew
he knew the producer anyway but he
wasn't in the right time right place
and all i did is bring it up at a dinner
and i said what's going on i said whoa
he's actually looking for work really
why did you have him give me a call it
was that easy
or it's that difficult if you're not at
that dinner
somebody else is going to get that job
now of course
he has the experience and all that stuff
we're not talking about that but we're
talking about the absolute
weird you know somebody leaves home
and you know at nine o'clock and if they
left at 9 30
the bus wouldn't have hit them we don't
know but it's weird
stuff going on you know so
yeah even if you
were able to look back at age 11 or
whenever it was
let's suppose you chose a different
route and that was to be
you know have your own carpet cleaning
business and you were the best carpet
cleaner in all of your
you know the tri-city area oh yeah do
you think that you'd be standing in that
same spot
saying i don't know this was real much
harder than i thought don't don't do you
think that
for every profession somebody goes to or
any endeavor
that most people say the same thing
that it was much harder than i thought
yes but
i think the film business even more so
because i don't
love the carpet cleaning business but no
you know i don't know how
50 000 scripts a year bouncing around
you know what i mean
everybody's trying to do the same thing
at least in la
many people are and across the world
everywhere because
you know everyone wants to be a
filmmaker you know and suddenly they'd
say oh everybody wants to be a filmmaker
really oh okay
like great when i was 11 not everybody
wanted to be a filmmaker you know we
we had our little weird click you know
of maybe five of us
but we were looked upon as you know the
film nerds like film
you know uh you know what i mean
so um it's the democratization of
filmmaking because it's
accessible to everybody so we all can
try it that's absolutely great
um but then you learn if you really have
a passion for it
and you can but then there's that other
thing
about getting a job you know you can
make your own movie that's fantastic but
so
you have to you know there's people make
movies and it's on amazon and that's
fine and
i know how many clicks it gets you know
if you want a wide range of something
you know it depends on how
how you set your goals and a lot of
times as the more you you know you get
knocked around in the business
uh many times your what's your vision of
what it was changes
just by the fact of you know you get
older
you know and you start to be like wow
okay well i wanted to
hit for that you know this and you go
i'm okay with this
you know you know i mean things change
from what you originally
thought at 11. but you got to keep that
wide-eyed dreamer alive otherwise it's
all gone
so that the 11 year old kid is still in
here somewhere
even though the jaded person is you know
uh but you got to keep that inside of
you because that what keeps you going
you know like like we were talking about
going to a movie theater in the popcorn
the lights go down and you're like take
me and
and you're like the magic of cinema the
movies you know and that's just what i
it just clicked with me it wasn't carpet
cleaning it wasn't
being a lawyer it was that's what i want
to do and thank
god i had a friend who got a camera
and maybe i would have you know
eventually got one of my own
but that spark sort of clicked at the
same time
you know so who knows i mean who's to
say and i had
very supportive parents that's also
important you know who said go for it
you know we never
got to do what we wanted and it's going
to be tough
but will be yours you know to back you
up and that
that helps to have someone in your
corner who believes in you
rather than you know has the the doubts
and you know whispers in you
oh what do you think you're gonna sell
something
yeah you're right all right i might as
well give it up now
you know get a refund for that software
you know
you know you think jade is being and i'm
not saying you're jaded
i'm not cheating i was joking but there
is a level that's needed don't you think
it's a self-pro
protective layer because sure absolutely
and it only comes from getting
like say knocked around uh
so the wide-eyed kid on one side and the
you know
the boxer on the other going i'm gonna
because i've been down that road before
i've been in that situation
i was taken advantage of because i
allowed it because i didn't i wasn't
smart enough
not smart enough but i didn't have the
information i needed to say no
and no is no okay thing to say when you
say this isn't for me
you're dangling you know carrots and
riches
and it's i'm walking away and i did to a
certain extent with that spec
a company wanted to buy it outright and
you know to tell me to walk away
and you know i needed the money at the
time sure it would have been it's not
you know life-changing money if it was
who's to say but it was sort of like
yeah okay
i can make matin you know how many
months doing my waiting job you know
but i wasn't gonna walk away i said this
doesn't feel right for me i'm gonna just
i'm gonna just
take this back and you know someday
somebody will find it and they did
and it happens and it doesn't happen but
there's no guarantees in this business
but the only guarantee as i always say
is the mantra
is that if you if you stop writing
you're really guaranteed to have no
chance of success
so you can only look in the mirror and
complain
um to yourself if you're not doing the
work
and you know you can blame hollywood you
can blame your agents you can blame
you know i'm a victim blah blah blah no
if you're not doing the work
then you only have yourself to blame
and the minute you stop doing the work
then you're out of the game
you're in the game doesn't mean if you
sold something or not as long as you're
writing screenplays and you've got a
you've got a cohesive plan and you've
got a schedule i was
reading something recently writer said
yeah i've do three scripts a year i'm
like that's great
i did three last year assignments but
um and you know try to work on a spec
but
okay but if you have a plan of what
you're going to do
not just not have a plan and kind of
wing it
time goes by so fast you know you turn
around it's five years and you're like
oh wow what what
what happened you know every year
re-evaluate i'm on my blog i have a
year-end
checklist it has seven points
and it says re-evaluate the last year
don't beat yourself
up but learn from it what what did you
excel in what did you fail in
you know where where's your strengths
and weaknesses like we were talking
about for writers what do you have to
improve on
you know take it seriously not just i'm
going to write a script
you know because it's you it's you
incorporated
you know there's no one out there
there's no one out there pushing you and
we all decided
to go down this journey no one forced
any of us you know so you have to take
responsibility
for yourself and also um
you know your career plans and what you
know your
what you're gonna do you know do you
write down
all of some of the things that you
thought you could improve on or you just
put that out there
like for for 2019 the end did you put
down specific things
that you oh in the blog yes
you did okay what were some of those
things that you um
either could have done better or that
you were really happy that you did well
uh
you know what projects did you work on
what did you have in your arsenal
was it scripts was it tv pilots was it
pitches was outlines
you know in your in your folder of where
wherever it is in your computer
um what's in your arsenal what do you
got you know
and what are you working on and what's
going to be finished first
and what do you think you know you got
to strategize and what are you going to
do with that script
what are your plans i'm going to enter
nickel fellowship great
i'm going to do this and that fantastic
i've got to
contact it blah blah blah you know
so now you have a you have a goal and
you set set those those goals and okay
where did you fail what did you make
mistakes on okay
i sent this script out too early you
know they gave me horrendous notes
you know or i had it i failed i didn't
get in this festival or whatever that's
again festival's a whole other story but
um
you can't look at his failure if you
didn't win a festival but i'm just
saying
things that you failers that you would
uh you expected to happen
in a positive manner that didn't that's
what i mean about that or or
outright failures they rejected the
script and said it was horrible
you know um things things of those that
nature
and um and then you know with networking
who did i meet
you know keep keep a log of that and and
follow up
new year's was a great is a great time
to send out that email hey
you know always look for a reason not
just a cold call email to somebody you
may have met it's like hey yeah we just
want to wish you happy new year i just
i hope your project's doing well i
happen to be working on this and bubba
but you know things like that
of that nature um cards are
old school but they're a great way again
if you get that card you know the uh
i was told that the assistants put the
handwritten cards on top of the mail
so when the mail comes in the
handwritten stuff's on top so whose card
is going to be there
hey happy new year and you're like hey
hey
were the mark guy you know and that yeah
yes there you go yeah that's my ride
it's taking you to the studio exactly um
so you know you remember that mark guy
yeah you know puts you back on the radar
and it's old school email's like so cold
and
you know um so various things like that
where you you look over the past year
and
analyze it honestly and and then
what are you going to do this year you
know what do you have plans i mean the
year goes by fast so what are you doing
you know instead of like well
you know i set up a set up a schedule i
want to finish the script by march
1st and damn it if i'm not going to meet
that and
i only have to do two pages a day great
rain or shine
just like talking about studying martial
arts rain or shine
my my sifu says did you study today i
said yes
okay don't and boy do talk about
procrastination
it's like yeah it's late you know you
know last night i
did my my training um and i didn't want
to
but it becomes ingrained where then you
do want to and then when you see results
of that you want to even more
because nothing's done if you don't do
it i mean it sounds so
simple but the same way with writing
you know so by march 1st i don't want to
hear somebody who committed to that made
a self-commitment to themselves which is
the worst thing for me to break a
commitment to myself
because you know i don't like to do it
to others but
to yourself um and you you he
unless something terrible comes up right
but you finish it by march you're like
damn i can hit a deadline
you know and i'm not expecting it to be
amazing but i got a first draft done and
now what are you gonna do with i'm gonna
go through the thing and you know
you know what i mean so uh it's just
being aware
of just not like treating it like a
business almost you know if like we have
to have plans for this thing that's
you the screenwriter to get you
to these different levels so would you
say
that you are a working screenwriter
seven days a week
in terms of you work on your career in
one fashion or
something i say screenwriters don't get
weekends off and
this weekend will be exactly the case
because today and before i came
i got notes again from a polish of a
script i've been
you know i wrote an assignment and um
you know i want to turn it around as
fast as possible because
um i want the thing made and so
you know um and there's sometimes but
something in my life
always has to do with screenwriting you
know
something always is something you can't
just uh there are times when i
can be away from it but then i start
getting antsy you know because i like to
work
and i like to create so um yeah it's a
big it's a big part which is the way
i've planned it
you know i want it to be a big part
of what i do so yeah
mark you added off camera some
interesting tidbit about writers that
you were maybe surprised by
yeah sometimes um when i consult i find
that writer is not able to
upon a second read um
execute those notes you know to make the
draft
like that much better or say well this
part wasn't working
and then it comes back and it's still
not working you know
and that's going to be a problem
in one's career if you can't execute
notes if you want to stay on
the idea is to stay on a project and not
get fired
not just sell a script you know because
it's gonna look bad if
if they take you off the project and um
yeah you might share credit but you'll
be known as like
you know you probably might not work
with that producer again because you
couldn't
execute the note you want to be the only
person on that
you know and it happens there are other
people that come in you know and
i've been on the other side where um
you know i was hired to rewrite a script
because the writer
was given many chances to do notes and
it just wasn't working
and so traditionally what they do i mean
they tend to say thank you very much but
we got to get somebody in here because
we're not going to trash the project
we're still going to make it but it's
not moving
where we need it to move you know so i
think that's
very important is to is to be able to
rewrite the script
and i think that comes from a place of
knowing structure knowing all the
elements that it takes to write a
screenplay
and many times like with the script i
had to
dismantle it to its essence and then
start again
you know like tear the house down but
leave the bathroom like okay but it's
still going to be a house
and we still want it to be you know
mediterranean style
you know with eight bedrooms you like
got it but all this other stuff
is not working and uh
you know like like i was telling you
off-camera about um i just finished
a polish um and then i got notes
this morning and it's a polish
so it's going through and refining you
know you know stuff it's not like
dismantling you know it's switching
things around and it's
maybe hopefully three or four days of
work
maybe five you know it's but it's not a
huge you know you want to get to that
point if you do a polish then you're
like oh okay
most of it's settled but this has to be
you know raised in this scene you know
it's too subtle
you know things like that or uh in this
case you know for reasons of production
so you go back through and you polish it
because you know we want to cut down the
number of scenes
we want to streamline this aspect things
like that but you have to be able to do
that
on your own screenplay you know if you
want to stay
on the project you know executing notes
is extremely important
do you think that the reason
screenwriters or maybe new screenwriters
aren't successful with that is a
resistance or
they don't understand it and they're not
trying to be difficult they just
can't see outside of their own
i think i think it's more that uh than
resistance
uh could be a little resistance because
my words my vision you know
and then you quickly learn like well it
it started to be your words and vision
and now it's a rewrite you know and
hopefully
a lot of it stays but it's a
collaborative art form and you want to
be a team player
to uh you know work once
you know like i say with my producer and
directors i work with you know
my once the script is now in the
development process
my job is to help get it made you know
and then
uh there are things that like i said
before you know you fight for
if you really believe in a change and
you'll talk
respectfully and maturely and say
because you're talking to other creative
people who aren't out to like
make a bad movie per se
sometimes it happens but you say well i
don't think
this would really work because of this
reason and as long as you defend it
you know with concrete evidence and then
you can convince
uh uh to keep it unchanged
but you also have to be open and more
times than not
um thank goodness there's a producer to
guide it because
you know i some of my choices are like
oh i get why you're doing that okay
oh okay i see yeah actually actually
that's better
so it's not about who thought of what
because you're all in you're all in it
together
you know you put the ego aside and
it becomes like let's just all work
together to get the movie made
you know the best version possible but
back to your
point about i do think it's just um
lack of experience possibly where
someone has never received notes maybe
they never had a critique on their
script so they wouldn't know how to go
back in
and make those changes so that
rewriting is a good way uh
you know rewriting your bad scripts
rewriting your good ones is a good way
to gain that experience over
multiple drafts and you know multiple
screenplays to be like okay i i know
what you're talking about
but then you'll get into a situation
where many producers are vague
you know what i mean and so there's no
school to go to where
a producer you know each like i said
before
each screenplay is a different
experience out of the gate different
producer different working experience
and one producer i worked with
i you know i tried to capture what he
was saying and i felt bad if i went oh
you know i don't quite understand
because then it makes me look like what
do you mean you don't understand
we hire oh and then i start feeling like
oh well
you know but it was all over bouncing
all over the map
big broad ideas that were changed on the
fly whoa um
did we go with this one or the other one
you know so you have to be available
ready for that
you know so um yeah there's all sorts of
situations but
um execution of the notes i i just
always have to say is extremely
important
yeah that was my next question that you
already went there but that was
what if it's not to let the writer off
the hook but
sure the the notes that are being given
are not clear
and so then the writers fighting against
that or not
but just or not even fighting but just
trying to understand sometimes you'll
have maybe
the assistant you can go off to and you
know because you don't want to
look like you don't know what you're
doing you know and talk to them
and they'll be more than happy to be oh
you know i'm speaking on behalf of
whatever
um but i've been lucky that that um
people i've worked with are like razor
sharp you know like okay pitch 48
you know and i love those kind of notes
i don't like the broad stroke notes
because it leaves it up to you and then
you go this way with it and they're like
i wanted you to paint this way with a
twist you're like
okay so you know and then it gets bogged
down in development hell
and no one's ever gonna say that it's
their fault
you know they're gonna you're not
working you know it's not working
and you just oh okay all right
so of the sag screeners that you saw or
of some of the screeners or the films
that you saw
for 2019 what was the best script what
was the best writing
of all of the films
well i saw um but you know it's funny
because it's
a script you know i look at i the
scripts are available so when you see
the movie i always look at the
screenplay
and like jojo rabbit was literally
on the page and some scripts you read
because you don't know what draft you're
getting
if it's a production draft or was the
final fine you know what i mean
and it was like oh that's because you
i always love to do that from years back
is to
see a movie you don't want to read the
script before because you'll ruin it
see the movie and then go back to see
like oh how would i have written that
scene and there's a particular scene i
won't say it in there
and i was like hmm and i looked and it
was exactly
you know we're not showing what we're
not showing and it was written on the
page and i was like wow that's
that's you know that's that's a good um
that's a good thing for writers to do as
well you know and
to read you have to read all the time
you know screenplays
and uh just i always say be careful of
the ones in awards season because
they're in a protected bubble so they're
not specs
so you can get away with a lot more
because you know it's it is in
development
you know what i'm saying then you're
spec i'm saying with regards to format
and things like that
because then you know what you want
because we're all
we're on this protected bubble now it's
not a speck where i don't know you
i'm just i can only know you from what's
on this page
you know what i mean so i see some
writers want to try to emulate certain
styles
you know what i mean but i just say be
careful because those are either the
directors
writing the script for the screen and
can put a lot more things in the script
than
let's say maybe a spec would or should
what about dialogue of the 2019
contenders that you watched
who had the best dialogue and what what
was it it's funny um
parasite you know was talking about
don't be afraid of the inch and a half
you know subtitles and i i've always
loved
foreign films so i had no problem with
subtitles
but yeah they all i mean once upon a
time the dialogue you know was
was really good i mean tarantino
but i mean they're all there for a
reason these movies you know what i mean
there's there's some that didn't get
nominated it was the snub
and you know but we all we all should um
champion a year of great filmmaking
you know rather than oh who didn't get
the award or who wasn't nominated you
know we have such a
wide choice of stories and things now to
to you know
it's gotten so much better um because
everybody's a game
you know the game goes up you know what
i mean and you can see like oh that's
not
you know and who benefits but the
filmmakers and also
the viewers you know i really like bruce
stern's dialogue
and once upon a time in hollywood that
was really funny that was supposed to be
uh burt reynolds
to play that part ah yeah he passed away
unfortunately
oh so yeah it's just interesting how
that would have made a different type of
character
you know i don't know because bruce dern
can kind of
uh disappear into a character
and bert was a great actor i think but
he's still burt reynolds sure
you know so how do you get around for
that and the last movie that he was in i
saw was
the what was it called um
it was his last film before he passed
away it was great he played a
aging film star who goes to a film
festival
i think it's called the last movie star
okay possibly yeah
does a screenwriter have to live in los
angeles preferably no
but but um it helps you know
tremendously to live in los angeles to
be around the business
there's no doubt about it uh like we
were talking about
earlier you could be out anywhere and
run into somebody
you know not that your choice of
networking but
you're around it there's so many any
night there's a screening
there's um academy screenings there's
writer's guild special things where you
can meet the filmmaker and
american cinema tech has it all the time
the filmmaker's there
you can ask questions you know to learn
and study
and you don't get that in
smaller places or places that aren't
hollywood you know
and now you can work it but let's say
you get a meeting you're going to have
to fly in and that meeting could end up
being
just a general meeting that yeah you'd
drive to pasadena for
you know 28 miles but you're going to
fly across the country
and it could end up you know you want to
maybe schedule a few of them
but you know what i mean it's sort of
it's it's not um it's not impossible
so no one should say well i don't live
in hollywood i won't be a screenwriter a
lot of people live outside of hollywood
but you're going to have to throw your
stuff into the ring
and come out for meetings and have that
expense be able to get off from work
these type of things and and
traditionally
um i don't know what town size that
somebody might be in
but you're not running in those circles
or somebody says hey
come to this party or i got the
screening you know to meet people
you know to put it out there uh or or
the festivals that that are here all the
time you know you can enter you can
enter your film
obviously from elsewhere but to go to
them
and network you know and stuff like that
so
um it's not impossible but there's so
much
here if you work it you know what i mean
if you
yeah what about not knowing the
temperament is the wrong word sort of
having a pulse on the end of such a
cliche or
having a pulse on the industry but
really there is a different
way of working in la and just because
somebody says great we'll be in touch
it doesn't mean that where it might mean
that more in the midwest where people oh
sure
might be more apt to keep their word and
or i'll read your screenplay
okay right so so six months later
and knowing that actually two years
later they could actually call you so
you don't want to get mad and shoot an
email
yeah how dare you know so there is like
this different
protocol here and and if you don't live
here
and you're around different surroundings
where things may mean what they mean
right then you hold them to a higher
standard which they they don't
they go we what did you mean you
believed me well i believe a person of
their word you expect me to be that way
well forget it jake it's hollywood you
know well sometimes
they keep their word it's just several
years later yes it just takes longer of
course yeah and and so
the natural inclination would be to be
hurt or angry and
but really if you just kept that door
open
it could actually happen yes you want to
burn any bridge ever right right
but maybe people don't understand that
there is like a different way
yeah they'll learn quickly if they if
they come out
here you know and and you know go wow
this is i
have to change my you know the way i
deal with people well
i wouldn't change myself i would still
be that person who you are i don't you
know drop to that but
it would be frustrating when no one else
like you were saying is
is plays that way they play with their
own rules
sure or you could be so
you wouldn't hear from someone for a
very long time and then the next thing
you know
now you're always hearing from them yeah
that kind of feast or famine sure yeah
yeah that happens so so from just
visiting here i don't
think you would get that no you wouldn't
just cut to come out for a meeting you'd
be wined and dined and
or maybe not maybe it's just a general
meeting you know me sometimes
a meeting is just a meeting get a soda
yeah cigar is just a cigar so um
people online oh i got a meeting you
know blah blah and they boast about
okay that's great um but what happens
when i've been to a million general
meetings myself and they just want to
meet you and say glad to meet you and
that's great
but it doesn't mean you know i i used to
love to have
oh my god i got a meeting you know
because
the potentiality of the whole thing you
know then you learn some people's job is
just to take a meeting
they want to have a face with a name and
that's it and maybe if you've got a
product and
you can show them a script that's
something great but it doesn't mean
they're going to buy it tomorrow
but you build on that you know you build
build build over a number of years
you know um so then being
oh sorry so then being here
it's not just the cost of going to a
meeting and getting off work and being
no it's also knowing how things work and
what
a word being uh
in a way in front of them more than out
somewhere where you know what i mean you
could potentially
i don't see you know if if i disappear
you're off my radar i mean you could
there's still email yes but i'm saying
that face to face like
and then what about the last minute
meeting that came up you're not going to
be able to get a plane flight
red eye to fly out you know what i mean
so if things bob and switch
you can tomorrow go oh my god i can i
can go to warner brothers
it just opened up or you know what i
mean so
you know but don't leave your family and
your job
and say i'm all in you know because it's
going to be rough
you know unless there's a guarantee like
they're flying you out
you know type of thing you know it's
it's a done deal they're buying the
script you know but
i just think living here puts you
around it all the time if that's on your
if that's what you want to do
you know what about
jinxing something by saying guess what i
got this
meeting or guess what of course all the
time that's why i tell
i have a blog article about you know
keep your
like in poker you know have your don't
spread it out there because
many times it's gonna bomb and then what
do you you know it's gonna look like
yeah you know you're boasting about this
meeting it could be it and you're let
down
um in front of everybody else you know
your your failures which is fine
but you don't want to present that too
much you know it's a private thing
you just say yeah i'm working on it you
know i got some meetings and it looks
good you know
because a lot of energy is spent and i
understand the anticipation the
excitement of it you know you want to
share that
but it's also a big fall you know
they're going to make the movie
well not until the check clears you know
i've been many many times and the head
of production goes oh we'll be shooting
in you know six weeks and
it's seven weeks what's going on you
know if i told everybody
you know oh i'm gonna quit my job and do
that you know
be a high big fall you know so it's a
lot easier
to blow just to be sort of even keel not
these
too hard to over the long haul to have
these big ups and downs it's just the
middle
the middle areas the best place to be
what's the best screenplay you've ever
read both
i've read quite a few good ones i
actually
i'm not gonna name his name but a close
friend of mine i read his script
and it was it was like i was re
i was seeing the movie i mean no i'm not
kidding
i saw the movie i mean sometimes you
read a script and you're you have to
conjure up
this was i was seeing the movie on the
page which
you hear and you you don't see a lot or
read a lot
and um it's one to be studied
by me as well because it was like wow he
really
worked a long time on it as well um
but that was one um recently that i read
was just
you know off the charts type of thing
and you you try and strive to be you
know to try to get to that point
obviously
and that's what rewriting does you know
to try to
whittle it down to its most effective
uh way of what you're trying to do
you know trying to present your story
how many people had seen
his script had read it to get it to that
stage
well it was a uh spec but it was
um it hadn't been made but it was a you
know professional
this is from a professional you know
screenwriter
um so it um
still to this day hasn't been made but
doesn't mean you know it's just
sometimes it happens
but were you the only person oh no no no
no no no
i had gotten a copy later i had no input
on or anything but i was just
i got a copy to read and i was like okay
i was like whoa you know
do you know how many uh eyeballs saw the
no it i mean it it had been around to
like real actors you know considering to
be in it type of thing and i can see why
wow because of how good it was you know
interesting
yeah and how long did it take for him to
earn it that didn't
know oh okay i'm not sure but i know
that wasn't the first draft
back to our point about you know first
drafts oh my god like yeah great
great starting point you know did he
outline
um i i'm sure he did because um he had
told me on his
recent film he big studio picture he had
outlined i may have to but it was like
50 page online
so i mean imagine that when people like
i don't want to outline try 50 pages
because it needs to be that before you
even get to
you know stuff so by that you'd be
you've worked out
you know it's just now write the script
pleasurable experience you know so
that's almost like
two minutes like i'm trying to think of
like what how does that break down
time-wise yeah i don't know you're right
it's a page or something or
yeah but it may not be because you never
i mean
yeah i don't know yeah yeah apparently
this could be
two minutes of screen time who knows i
mean that's true
why would a writer stop writing writer
would stop writing
when they have nothing else to say maybe
you know or they would stop writing
because they haven't achieved
a level where they thought they would be
maybe i'm giving up
you know i'm not i didn't sell an a-list
script
i'm going to go sell carpets you know
carpet cleaning something whatever job
it is
um you would hope that a writer would
you know would stay in the game and
because
we got you know like officer gentlemen i
got nowhere else to go
you know i got nothing else i want to do
you know i i
i need to tell stories
i'm a storyteller you know and it's
tragic when you hear people
writers you know give up and i
understand because
everybody has their limits and they you
know it's like
it's uh and you know it could be not
giving up
let's say pursuing it full-time but
maybe dabbling on the side and then that
takes longer and sure life can get in
the way and then
you know it's it it falls along the
wayside and maybe wasn't
as interesting of a pursuit as the
writer thought it was
you know and because it went up against
that test
you know the difficulty test and
you know that's always like i say how
badly do you want it rejection criticism
failure that's usually the litmus test
of how bad you want to be in this you
know because
we're all gonna experience in that even
after you make it you start working
you're gonna be fired you know and stuff
um
so yeah all fear
too maybe i'll never you know achieve
what i
thought i would you know but i say the
longer you're in it that kind of changes
too
just by its nature of being in this you
know at least for me
how you look at things you know so it
could be a number of reasons why someone
quits
you know but i always it's always a sad
day for me to hear that going ah one of
her
you know brethren her sisters stopped
you know they you know maybe it would
just be around that next corner
you know maybe it's that next script but
that's also the
chasing the dragon you know like well
not this one
and we all have to maybe it's the next
one maybe it's the one after that
and then you know what i mean so
everybody has to have their own
uh self-reflection about you know how
long you're going to give this
you know i like i say i never put an
expiration date on my screenwriting
dream so i didn't say but by this date i
have to
you know and thank goodness stuff worked
out a bit
you know but i don't know if i was doing
it for 10
15 years and there was no forward
movement what i would
think about it you know so i think it's
a personal thing everyone has to every
writer has to ask themselves
so when you started writing you had one
mindset
for it and now you've gone into
something that's just maybe a little
more relaxed or real
okay realistic okay yeah not relaxed
about the work by the way but just
know about about certain goals and and
in terms of yeah sure it has to be
you know i have to be here by this point
kind of thing yeah
or what you want to do don't you want to
direct it's like
you know i'd rather produce and write
you know directing
there's a lot of directors you know and
having done it in film school yeah but i
have no project to show someone it's
like oh you're
you're the one over this person in fact
i would probably
um on a project step aside and let
a director who i would pick direct the
movie that's more of a producer's
thing you know um
so i don't know it changes you know out
of film school
i kind of always wanted to be a writer
but then the longer you're in the
business you go hmm
writers get kicked around a lot stuff
gets changed a lot
and you're always at the mercy of
someone else hiring you
but if you're a producer writer or you
move into producing where you say this
is my project
you don't get it i'm going to put the
elements together
you know and i now i'm a producer you
know type of thing so
things can change since our last
interview which was
2017 i believe around the holidays yeah
have you changed your mind about any of
the writing process
maybe you were in one camp where you
said
i'm not going to do it this way or i
only do it this way and then now
several years later you've changed where
you've loosened up on that
or you've completely anything about the
writing process
that has changed for you where you were
very dogmatic about something and then
um i don't know i think the dog was
still there
but i think the process of being uh
i wanted to get back to more like i can
remember the days when ideas would just
pop up you know and this and that
and uh i would find an idea that i would
be so passionate about that i would see
it ah
you know and you know when you're
working on assignments it's kind of
different
i mean you have to do that but it's
it's you know i i like uh
what i'm trying to say is i want to get
back into more of that
spec stuff for me cells are not whatever
you know i've got um other spec uh ideas
that i
have are pretty decent shape they've
been you know i pitched them and they've
been around and stuff
but um to maybe take one and and expand
it into something else instead of a tv
pilot make it a feature or maybe write a
book of it you know type of thing so
i'm one thing i would say is i'm opening
my mind more to different
creative possibilities than just the the
straight and narrow type
um so yeah in that way
but the way that the way that um
i work no you know i'm open to
suggestion but so far you know um it
seems to work
you know for what i'm doing so
yeah but i'm always open to you know
you always have to be you know like
water flows you know so it's like
is that part of the tai chi you think
either the tai chi
changed that or you already changed and
then you wanted to do the tai chi
because it's kind of about the flow of
energy and different things
yeah i think um that's going to help me
more in this next
plateau you know in in
in studying the certain philosophies to
try to um
uh you know have them dictate toward
writing
in a way you know trying to make them
sort of similar or it's life you know i
mean
these kind of philosophies are for life
too as well you know
discipline right you know patience
things like that and with tai chi
it's not if you hit back it's you shift
your energy
yeah it's it's it you're always you're
always it's a flow
you know what i mean so it's um trying
to flow through life
that's what i'm trying to do and uh
you know when you come up against these
hurdles with screenwriting
um not to take them as the end-all
be-all
your life's over type of thing you know
and i say that for beginning riders as
well
you know especially because you're going
to hit a lot of knocks that you could
want to give up you're going to say well
i'm not i'm not selling anything and
nobody's reading my stuff or how do i
get to do that and
you find a way you find you find that
one move that works
you know but yeah i saw a documentary uh
came out i think 2019 about miles davis
career
and he reinvented himself so many times
yes and there were times when he wanted
to give up or
sure different things happen with his
health but yeah he was always kind of
reinventing himself
because you had you know he spans so
much time
that he you can't keep doing the stuff
back
you know you were doing in the 60s you
know you have to evolve in
and change you know and so um yeah i
believe in that too you have to
as you grow as a person you know so too
you have to grow as a screenwriter
you know what i mean and uh it's
storytelling
so right so he would infuse different
things i think he did like sort of
he had a more latin percussion phase
that he
put into his music and different things
with different costumes different looks
and it really helped keep this career
going yeah and it keeps you fresh that's
the key
you know and you don't look at it's like
this thing you know that i have to do
you come back to it from that 11 year
old kid that was like oh
this thing that i love to do that i'm
blessed to do that i'm blessed to get
paid to do
you know i was blessed to do it anyway
but get paid is even better
you know because so yeah